MORNING- I AM CALLING THIS
JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER TWO ON
EDUCATION AND FINANCE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES I
SEE SOME OF THE CHAIRS ARE HERE
NOW- SOME OF THE- THEY ARE HERE
SO WE WITH THE MISSION TODAY IS
TO HAVE A VERY FRANK DISCUSSION
ABOUT IMPROVING ACCESS. TO
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. IT'S NOT THAT
WE NEED TO DO IT IT'S ABOUT HOW
WE DO IT IS ABOUT THE LOGISTICS
AND MECHANICS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT PROVIDING
THESE SERVICES AND THEN OFTEN
BILLING BACK EITHER INSURANCE
COMPANY MEDIC CAL AND SO FORTH
TO PAY FOR THOSE SERVICES.
BECAUSE THEY ARE COSTLY TO
PROVIDE NO DOUBT AND WE WANT
DISTRICTS TO RECOUP THAT MONEY
HOW OFTEN IT COMES FROM FEDERAL
SOURCES AS WELL. AND IT IS THE
PERCEPTION OF MANY THAT THE
RULES ARE COMPLEX HARD FOR
DISTRICTS TO FOLLOW HARD FOR
DISTRICTS TO LEARN. AND SO THEY
DID TAKE A PASS OFTEN AND DON'T
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM SO
AGAIN THE DISCUSSION TODAY IS
NOT THAT WE NEED TO DO IT. IT
IS THE HOW WE DO IT- SO I'M
CONGRESS MORE TO THIS MEETING
TO ORDER. ASSURING IS JOINTLY
SPONSORED. BY THE ASSEMBLY AND
COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION. AND
HEALTH AS WELL AS BUDGET SOME
COMMITTEES NUMBER ONE AND TWO.
BEFORE YOU GET AGENDA I HAVE A
STATEMENT TO READ READ
REGARDING OUR PROCESS. THE
ASSEMBLY IS REQUIRING THAT MASK
YOU WORN BY PEOPLE PRESENT IN
THE HEARING ROOM TODAY IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASS WE WILL
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. IF ANY
MEMBER IN THE ROOM IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO RIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE WHEN WE INVITE
PUBLIC COMMENT. FROM PEOPLE IN
THE ROOM. WE WILL ALSO BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE LIMITED TO ONE
PERSON PER. ONE MINUTE PER
PERSON AND WILL BE LIMITED TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES OVERALL WE DO
HAVE A HEARING AFTER THIS. IN
THIS ROOM. SO WE NEED TO CLEAR
OUT IN TIME FOR THE ROOM WE
CLEARED. CLEANED RATHER. AND
FOR THEM TO SET UP FOR THE NEXT
HEARING. IT IS A TIMELY
PROCESS. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR
TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS
WELL AS ON YOUR SCREEN TYLER
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING ON
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS WE
REACH THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OF THE HEARING. HEY
PLEASE FOLLOW THE MODERATORS
INSTRUCTIONS. AND SPEAK TO THE
ISSUE AT HAND ONLY. YOU WILL
HAVE A MAXIMUM ONE MINUTE WHEN
THAT TIME WHEN IT IS TIME TO
HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC. AGAIN
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
WHEN YOU DO CALL IN. IF YOU
HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH A
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE OFFICE AT.
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO EIGHT SEVEN. THERE IS
LSO A REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
IN CAPITOL PARK ON THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL IT'S
OUTSIDE YOU CAN WALK UP TO IT.
YEAH I WANTED THIS TIME YOU MAY
PROVIDE TESTIMONY FROM THAT
SPOT AS WELL. THE COMMITTEE
ALSO ACCEPTS WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE CMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE WE DO ACCEPT COMMON.
THROUGH THAT WEBSITE- PORTAL.
FOR OFFER ANY DISRUPTIONS WILL
NOT BE PUT UP WITH. ALL IN THE
HEARING ROOM TODAY. CANNOT
REMOVE A MASK YOU- YOU MUST YOU
MUST KNOW REMOVING A MASKED
TALKING MAKING LOUD NOISES FROM
THE AUDIENCE I DON'T ALLOW OR
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE. SPEAKING LONGER THAN
THE TIME A LOT OF YOU WILL BE
CUT OFF I WILL ASK THE
MODERATOR AT ONE MINUTE. TO CUT
OFF THE SPEAKERS. EXTENDED
DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING. BY A AND. AND OR OTHER
DESTRUCTIVE ACTS- TO. THE
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT- US TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL TO STRUCTURE HEARING
PROCESS I WILL THEN DIRECT THEM
TO STOP. WARN THEM AND THEN IT
CONTINUED- DISRUPTIONS WILL-
WILL WILL. IT WOULD LEAD TO
REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING THERE WILL ALSO BE
DOCUMENTED- AND THERE IT IS- SO
WITH THAT LET'S GET UNDER
HEARING- AND AGAIN THANK YOU
ALL FOR PARTICIPATING TODAY
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT. WE
VERY MUCH RECOGNIZE THAT
BECAUSE IS ABOUT KEEPING
CHILDREN HEALTHY AND GETTING
THEM AND KEEPING THEM IN
SCHOOL. THE PANDEMIC HAS
HIGHLIGHTED. THE FOR US THE
CRITICAL LINK BETWEEN STUDENT
HEALTH AND WELL BEING AND THEIR
OVERALL ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE.
WE KNOW THAT PROVIDING HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT
SCHOOL SITES IS AN EFFECTIVE
METHOD OF MEETING THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS. FOR TOO LONG OUR
SYSTEM OF PROVIDING LAW SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. HAS PROVEN OVERLY
COMPLEX AND BURDENSOME
BURDENSOME. SCHOOLS OFTEN FAIL
TO PARTICIPATE IN MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAMS OR ONLY
BILL FOR PORTION OF THE
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE LEAVING
FEDERAL MONEY. ON THE TABLE.
AND IT ALSO TAKING VALUABLE
DOLLARS AWAY FROM THE CLASSROOM
DISTRICTS JUST SIT IT OUT. BOB
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS
COUNTY AGES IS COUNTY AGENCIES
AND COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS
OFFER ANOTHER WAY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO STUDENTS BUT AGAIN
TOO FEW OF THESE PARTNERSHIPS
EXIST. AS A RESULT TOO MANY
STUDENTS DO NOT RECEIVE THE
SERVICES THEY ARE LEGALLY
ENTITLED TO. THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR MADE
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS IN
STUDENT HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH IN THIS BUDGET CYCLE TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTED THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND G.
H. C. S. TO FORM A WORK GROUP
TO STUDY THIS ISSUE TO IDENTIFY
THE BARRIERS. TO REPORT TO BILL
FOR THE SERVICES AND TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE ACCESS WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO HEAR ABOUT CONCRETE ACTIONS
THAT CAN AND WILL BE TAKEN TO
ADDRESS. THIS CRITICAL NEED
AGAIN THAT'S THE LOGISTICS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING THE
SERVICES AND RECOUPING THE COST
FOR PROVIDING THE SERVICES.
FIRST WE WILL HEAR FROM WEST ED
THE CONTRACTOR HIRED TO
FACILITATE THIS WORKGROUP.
ABOUT THE PROCESS THAT WAS
UNDERTAKEN IN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED. FOLLOWING THEIR
PRESENTATION WE'LL HEAR FROM
TWO STATE AGENCIES CD AND DH CS
REGARDING THEIR PLANS TO
IMPLEMENT RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE REPORT AS WELL AS ACTIONS
TAKEN IN THE BUDGET TO ADDRESS
THE NEED TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
SCHOOL BASED. HEALTH CARE.
FINALLY WE'LL HEAR FROM
STAKEHOLDERS IN BOTH EDUCATION
AND HEALTH FIELDS WITH THEIR
THOUGHTS ON KEY BARRIERS AND
THE PROPOSED SOLUTIONS.
BIOGRAPHY BIOGRAPHIES OF ALL
OUR SPEAKERS ARE INCLUDED IN
YOUR HEARING PACKETS AND ARE
POSTED ON THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION WEBSITE. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WELL AND WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT AND I'D LIKE TO
INVITE MY COLLEAGUES IF THEY
HAD ANY OPENING REMARKS TO
SHARE THOSE REMARKS RIGHT NOW
WANT TO GO STRAIGHT DOWN WILL
START WITH MISTER WHAT LOOKS
READY. SO DOCTOR WOULD IF YOU
HAVE ANY JUST LOOKING FORWARD
TO DISCUSSIONS MORNING. GREG
THIS WALDRON ANY. THANK YOU- AS
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN WORKING IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH SPACE FOR A
LONG TIME I'M VERY INTERESTED
IN HEARING MORE ABOUT HOW
WE'RE- ALLOWING OUR KIDS TO GET
MORE ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
EARLIER. ADULT ARAMBULA THANK
YOU- FIRST TIME QUITE
APPRECIATIVE TO BE HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES SEEING MANY OF THEM
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
SEPTEMBER TENTH IT'S GREAT TO
SEE YOU AND TO BE WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE BUT I DO WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK THE
ENTIRE WORK GROUP WHO FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON MANY OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND- DIGGING
INTO A SUBJECT AREA THAT IS
AWFULLY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
ADDRESS AND- TO START TO BREAK
DOWN SILOS. AND SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO A CONVERSATION TODAY
ABOUT HOW WE CAN HELP WITH AN
EDUCATION TO ADVANCE SOME OF
THE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND BELIEVE THERE'S A
REAL OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO LOOK
TO PULLING DOWN INCREASED
FEDERAL FUNDING THROUGH THESE
PARTNERSHIPS AND HOPE THAT WE
CAN CREATE SOME CONVERSATIONS
TODAY ABOUT HOW THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY BENEFIT OUR STUDENTS
WE HAVE A REAL CHANCE HERE WHEN
YOU INVEST IN SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
EDUCATION AND HEALTH OUTCOMES.
AND IT'S A GREAT WAY FOR US TO
WORK TOWARDS EQUITY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY. I MISS RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NOW I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO THINK- YOU AND THE REST
OF THE GROUP FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM ALL OF THE-
PANELISTS. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
ANOTHER BUS CONVERSATION THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU AND THIS
IS REALLY OUR OUR OPPORTUNITY
AS MEMBERS LEGISLATURE TO
REALLY CONNECT WHAT'S GOING ON.
DEMOGRAPHIC WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE DISTRICT LEVEL THIS IS YOUR
CHANCE TO INFORM US SO WE CAN
GIVE YOU. THE RESOURCES.
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES BECAUSE THESE SERVICES
ARE VERY IMPORTANT. I WAS TIED
TAUGHT SEVENTH GRADE ON MONDAY.
OKAY OKAY GREAT ON FRIDAY- BUT
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S VERY
INTERESTING WHAT'S GOING ON IN
OUR SCHOOL SITES LOGISTICALLY.
WITH THE PANDEMIC AND ALSO FROM
A MENTAL HEALTH AND ACADEMIC
PERSPECTIVE. IT'S VERY
INTERESTING TO WALK INTO A
CLASSROOM IT'S HURT A LOT OF
PEOPLE UP HERE SAY HEY SCHOOLS
NEEDED TO THE SCHOOLS NEED TO
DO THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT
IS VERY DIFFERENT. WHEN YOU
WALK INTO THE CLASSROOM AND SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON AND KNOW THAT
SOME STUDENTS ARE QUARANTINE.
AND I'M NOT THERE THAT DAY AND-
THAT THERE WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE PANDEMIC AND IS IT IS
JUST VERY. INTERESTING AND YOU
KNOW VERY EDUCATING A WALK IN
THE UNDER SCHOOL SITE SEE THAT
HAPPENING RATHER THAN JUST
TRYING COMMANDED FROM THE
SACRAMENTO LEVEL. SO TODAY WE
HEAR FROM SOME PROTECT COMES
FROM SOME POINT PRACTITIONER
PRACTITIONER SO I APPRECIATE
THAT OPPORTUNITY WITH THAT
WE'LL GO TO OUR FIRST PANEL
WHICH WE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
WEST AT WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF SB
SEVENTY FIVE. AT THE SB SEVENTY
FIVE FINAL REPORT THIS REPORT
IS ALSO POSTED ON THE EDUCATION
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION WEBSITE THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE YOU CAN GO THERE AND
SEE THIS REPORT- AGAIN IT IS OF
THESE ARE FOLKS FROM WESTERN.
JASON WILLIS IS HERE WITH US IN
THE HEARING ROOM TODAY AND HE
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY HIS
COLLEAGUES. TIE RIP MA AND
AMBER VALDEZ VIA VIDEO
CONFERENCE SO AGAIN JASON
WILLIS REQUESTED IS HERE WHAT
THEY DID IS THEY PUT UP THEY
THEY PUT TOGETHER A REPORT-
KINDA INFORM THE LEGISLATURE.
AND SO HE HAD AGAIN JASON
WALLACE IS HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THAT WITH HIS
COLLEAGUES. MISTER. WILLIS YOU
MAY PERCEIVE ONE RIGHT- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. TWENTY PRESS THE-
MEGA. THANK YOU- CHAIRED-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HAVING US HERE THIS MORNING- I-
WANT TO. START BY SAYING ADAM-
JUST WITH GREAT APPRECIATION-
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO CREATING
THIS OPPORTUNITY- FOR THE STATE
AGENCIES AND VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS TO COME TOGETHER.
IN A VERY UNIQUE WAY- AND
PRIVILEGE THAT WEST I HAD A
CHANCE TO REALLY HELP
FACILITATE. AND MOVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS FORWARD OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS- AND I'M
APPRECIATIVE TO THE WEST A TEAM
THE OVER TWO DOZEN STAFF- THAT
HELP TO SUPPORT THE STATE
AGENCIES AND TO SUPPORT THE
STAKEHOLDERS- IN COMING UP WITH
WHAT YOU NOW HAVE- AS THE
FINAL- SB SEVENTY FIVE MEDIC
COW FOR STUDENTS WORKGROUP
REPORT AND THE ASSOCIATED
ADDENDUM SO. I'M PART TIME-
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF FOR THIS
PANEL IS- CAN OFFER SOME VERY-
BASIC HIGH LEVEL INFORMATION
ABOUT THE PROCESS. ABOUT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE ARRIVED
AT AND ALSO SOME OBSERVATIONS
AROUND WHAT RESULTED- THINGS
THAT WERE- THEY CAME TOGETHER
FOR BOTH THE STATE AGENCIES BUT
ALSO FOR THE STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS- WE CAN GO TO SIDE. FOR
PLEASE. GREAT SO I JUST AS A
REMINDER TO THE COMMITTEE AND
TO THE PUBLIC- THIS WAS THE
AUTHORIZING LEGISLATION- THAT
ALLOWED THIS WORKER TO PROCEED-
BEGINNING IN- WITH THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN- WE HAD-
TWO YEARS IN WHICH TO COMPLETE
THE WORK. ORIGINALLY ON A
TIMELINE OF ONE YEAR BUT THE
ADDITIONAL YEAR ADDED AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO GO
FURTHER AND DEEPER- THE
RESULTED IN SOME VERY- SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT- SHOWS
CONSENSUS. BETWEEN BOTH
STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL AS A
RECOGNITION OF HOW THIS SPACE
AROUND BRINGING. SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH SERVICES INTO SCHOOLS
CAN HAPPEN IN A MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT. AND EFFECTIVE MANNER.
SO WHEN I TALK FOR JUST A
MOMENT ABOUT- THE PROCESS BY
WHICH WE USE WE GO TO THE NEXT
SLIDE- IN ORDER TO ARRIVE. AT
WHAT YOU HAVE IN THE FINAL
REPORT- THAT REALLY USED TO
KIND OF THREE STAGE PROCESS
FIRST. TO UNDERSTAND AND
INTERROGATE THE CHALLENGE THAT-
WAS PRESENTED BY BRINGING MORE
OF THESE MENTAL. AND HEALTHY
SERVICES INTO SCHOOLS AND IN
PARTICULAR WAS REALLY ASSESSING
THE SYSTEM BARRIERS- STRENGTHS
AND OPPORTUNITIES. THAT LED TO
A SET OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
VARIOUS IDEAS THAT COULD
BASICALLY BE IMPLEMENTED AS A
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THOSE
CHALLENGES. THAT WE SAW AT
DIFFERENT STAGES OF THE SYSTEM.
AND THOSE SET OF IDEAS WERE
THEN WORKED OVER WITHIN SEVERAL
SUBGROUPS- IN THE IN THE WORK
GROUPS THAT INCLUDED BOTH
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ACROSS
SECTION. OF VARIOUS PLACES
ACROSS CALIFORNIAIN BOTH THE
EDUCATION AND IN THE HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH FIELDS. THAT WERE
ALSO SUPPLEMENTED BY STAFF FROM
VARIOUS STATE AGENCIES THAT
WERE INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES THAT
WERE THERE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
AND GUIDANCE- IN CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS AS THE WORKER FOR
COMING UP WITH A SET OF
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE NOW
REPRESENTED. AS
RECOMMENDATIONS- IN THE REPORT
WHICH WAS THE FINAL STAGE OF
THE PROCESS. THAT INCLUDED THE
REPORT WRITING PROCESS- IN
WHICH THE STAKEHOLDERS HAD
OPPORTUNITY IN WHICH TO REVIEW
AN OFFER FEEDBACK- AND MOVED
ITS WAY THROUGH BOTH OF THE
STATE AGENCIES BEFORE FINALLY
BEING PUBLISHED. ON OCTOBER
FIRST. SO ON THE NEXT SIDE I
JUST WANNA TALK FOR. JUST A
MOMENT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
TIMELINE OF THAT PROCESS AND
YOU CAN SEE EACH OF THOSE STEPS
OF THEIR KIND OF LAID OUT HERE
ON THE SLIDE. THAT STARTED WITH
THAT FIRST- WORKGROUP MEETING
IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY-
AND WENT THROUGH AN INTERNET
PROCESS IN WHICH WE WERE DOING
WORK IN BETWEEN THE
STAKEHOLDER- MEETINGS WORKING
WITH THE STEERING COMMITTEE
THAT WAS PRIMARILY MADE UP OF-
WEST AT STAFF HELPING BOTH
STATE AGENCIES THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. I TO
BRING TOGETHER THAT INFORMATION
AND FORM IT INTO THE NEXT
WORKGROUP MEETING SUBSEQUENT TO
THE LAST ONE. AND YOU CAN SEE
THAT PROGRESS REPORT THAT WE
PUBLISHED IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY THAT WAS OF A
SUBSTANTIAL MILESTONE IN MOVING
INTO. THE RECOMMENDATIONS
DEVELOPMENT WHICH WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR THE- THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THIS- THIS PREVIOUS
YEAR. RESULTING IN THIS FINAL
REPORT SO. HELPFUL HOPEFULLY TO
LAY OUT SOME OF THE PARTS OF
THE PROCESS- HOUSE STAKEHOLDERS
ARE INVOLVED HAVE THE STATE
AGENCIES WERE INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS. AND I WANT TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TIE REMOTE
WHO'S GOING TO GO OVER SOME OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE-
WRITTEN UP AND PROVIDED IN THE
REPORT. THANK DJS AND GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE-
EVEN THOUGH I HAD TO GO TO THE
NEXT SLIDE. AND THEN AT PRESENT
THAT MEDICAL FOR STUDENTS
WORKGROUP RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE FINAL REPORT. AND YOU'LL
SEE THAT THE ON THE NEXT SIDE
THAT THE WORKGROUP
RECOMMENDATIONS FALL INTO FIVE
BROAD AREAS. STATE INTERAGENCY
COLLABORATION LOCAL AGENCY
TRAINING GUIDANCE. SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH SERVICES DEMONSTRATION
FOR AIDS. LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY BILLING OPTION PROGRAM
ON IT SUPPORT. AND ACCESS TO
PREVENTIVE SERVICES. I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD AND MOVE THROUGH EACH
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
ASSOCIATED ACTIONS NOW ONE BY
ONE. ON THE NEXT SLIDE
RECOMMENDATION ONE. IS TO
FORMALIZE STATE LEVEL
COLLABORATION BETWEEN EDUCATION
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS. ASSEMBLY
ACTION ONE HEY ASKED WE PROVIDE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES SO THAT THEY CAN
HIRE AND RETAIN DEDICATED STAFF
TO ESTABLISH A SYSTEM OF
ONGOING STATE LEVEL
COLLABORATION. AND ONE BE
UTILIZED ADVISORY GROUP TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS AND PROVIDE
GUIDANCE RELATED TO
COLLABORATION BETWEEN
EDUCATIONAL HEALTH SYSTEMS. AND
THE WORKER FOR THE RECOGNIZE
THAT THE ADVISORY GROUP THAT
INCLUDED AT PORT STAKEHOLDERS
AND THOSE ARE USING FAMILIES
REPRESENTATIVES FROM
DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION. DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND SERVICES
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY BROADLY
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. AND THEY ALSO
RECOMMEND INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES TO COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS MANAGED CARE PLANS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AS WELL. AND RECOMMENDATION
NUMBER TWO IS TO PROVIDE
TARGETED TRAINING AND GUIDANCE
TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
ARE ONLY AS- AND HEALTH PLANS
AS WELL ON IMPLEMENTING SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH PROGRAMS TO
MAXIMIZE BILLING AND
REIMBURSEMENTS ON SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CARE EXPENDITURES. AND
ALSO TO EXPAND ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE SERVICES FOR MEDICAID
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. ACTION EIGHT
HERE'S YOUR PRODUCE TRAINING
AND TARGETED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES FOR
EDUCATION HEALTH SYSTEM
PROVIDERS INCLUDING
SPECIFICALLY ELEAZAR COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS AND MANAGED
CARE PLANS. SB IT IS TO CREATE
CONDITIONS THAT WILL ENABLE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN HEALTH
PLANS AT LEAST FLOURISH AND
MUCH OF THIS CONVERSATION AMONG
THE WORKGROUP MEMBERS WAS
RELATED TO ACTING LIKE SHARED
OWNERSHIP. AND FOCUSING ON THE
CHILD AS THE CENTER OF SERVICES
IN THE WORK WE DO. AND IN
ADDITION WHERE IT'S APPROPRIATE
AND WORK LEGALLY ALLOWABLE
WORKGROUP RECOMMENDS WE
ENCOURAGE CONTRACTS AND
MEMORANDUMS OF UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN ELEAZAR AND MANAGED
CARE PLANS AS WELL AS COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS. AND
RECOMMENDATION THREE IS TO
CREATE A SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
SERVICES DEMONSTRATION SITES TO
IMPROVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THAT'S PROVIDED DELEGATES ABOUT
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH AND TO
CAPITALIZE ON THE RECENT SCHOOL
BASED MEDICAID INVESTMENTS AND
INITIATIVES. THE FIRST ACTION
HERE IS TO ENGAGE A CONTRACTOR
TO PILOT LISTS GT'S DANCE
FOCUSED ON SOME EXTRACTIONS.
ASSEMBLY TO LEARN WORKS TO
SCALE UP THESE PROGRAMS AND
EXPAND ON. AND SPECIFICALLY THE
WORKGROUP WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT THE DEMONSTRATION SITES
LEVERAGE THE NEW SCHOOL BASED
MEDICAID INVESTMENTS AND
INITIATIVES. FIRSTLY PRODUCED
EFFECTIVE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
ELEAZAR- MANAGED CARE PLANS
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS AND ONLY
A POP AND SCHOOL BASED MEDIC
HOW ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITY IS
NOT A SMALL PROGRAM VENDORS AND
THEN SECOND TO PROVIDE A WIDE
ARRAY OF SERVICES TO MEDICAID
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. AND END OF A
BIG DEAL HERE SPEAKING ABOUT IN
TERMS OF ALL THREE MEDICAID
ACCESS POINTS SO THERE ARE
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS THE STATE
CURRENTLY THAT I UTILIZE WONDER
OR TO OUR PORTION OF THESE
TYPES O PARTNERSHIPS BUT THE
IDEA BEING THAT THESE
DEMONSTRATION SITES WOULD BUT
HAVE ALL THREE OF THOSE THREE
BEING. COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS MANAGED CARE PLANS AND
FINALLY THE. ONLY A BLOCK AND A
SMALL PROGRAM. AND THEN.
APPLIED LESSONS. THAT THAT WE
LEARN FROM THESE BASED OUT
SERVICES DEMONSTRATE SITES TO
INFORM THE FUTURE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT'S PROVIDED TO
ALL THE IS AND ALSO TO HELP
WITH. AND RECOMMENDATION NUMBER
FOUR TO FACILITATE THE L. A.
BILLING OPTION PROGRAM OR ALL
THE L. A. BACH AUDIT PROCESS.
THE WORKER RECOMMENDS
IMPLEMENTING FEEDBACK LOOPS
BETWEEN ELLIE A IS AND THE DHS
ON ITS INVESTIGATION DIVISION.
THAT FOSTER COLLABORATIVE
LEARNING AND CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT AND THEN ALSO
DEVELOPING RESOURCES THAT
SUPPORT ELLIE A AUDIT
PREPARATION SPECIFICALLY- SO
FIRST ACTION HERE IS TO ENHANCE
UNDER PROCESSES THROUGH AUDITOR
TRAINING. INFORMED BY USER
EXPERIENCE AND SPECIFICALLYTHE
EXPERIENCE. OF THOSE THERE ON
THE GROUND AND ELEAZAR. AND
GATHERING REGULAR FEEDBACK FOR
MILLIONS ABOUT THERE. ON IT
EXPERIENCES. SB DEVELOP AUDIT
RELATED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROCESS SEEKS TO SUPPORT
ELEAZAR BEFORE DURING AND AFTER
THE L. A. BACH AUDIT PROCESS.
AND THEN FINALLY RECOMMENDATION
NUMBER FIVE. IS TO IDENTIFY
OPTIONS FOR EXPANDING ACCESS TO
SCHOOL BASED PREVENTIVE
PHYSICAL HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES. AND ACTION EIGHT HERE
IS TO IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT AND SCHOOLS WHEN THE
CHILD HAS THE RISK FACTORS BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE A DIAGNOSIS
THAT QUALIFIES THEM FOR
SERVICES. AND THEN BEAT TO
DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK FOR SCHOOL
BASED PREVENTIVE PHYSICAL
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES
AND THE WORKGROUP KNOWS THAT
THIS SHOULD BE DONE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH NATIONAL
GUIDELINES FOR SUCH SERVICES.
AND SPECIFICALLY THAT THE FREE
MARKET IDENTIFIED THE FUNDING
SOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
EACH SERVICE. SO THOSE ARE THE
WORKGROUP AND RECOMMENDATIONS
AS A PARENT APART AND I'M GONNA
GO AHEAD AND TURN IT OVER TO
AMBER AND CHECK. THIS OUT.
NUMBER. THANK YOU SO MUCH HI
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME
IS AMBER ABOUT THAT AND I'M A
SENIOR ASSOCIATE AND CO
DIRECTOR OF THE MEDICAL FOR
STUDENTS PROJECT THAT WEST AND
I'M GOING TO BRIEFLY SHARE SOME
ADDITIONAL OUTCOMES OF THE
MEDICAL FOR STUDENTS WORKGROUP
RECOMMENDATION DEVELOPMENT.
PROCESS WHILE THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR A MAJOR
OUTCOME OFTHIS WORK SO TOO ARE
THE RELATIONAL AND WHARNCLIFFE
ALCHEMY OF THE PROJECT MOST
NOTABLY OUTCOMES RELATED TO.
INTER AGENCY COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE STATE AGENCIES
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WITH
EDUCATION AND HEALTH
REPRESENTATIVES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND FINALLY SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY ACROSS THE STATE
AGENCIES AND ALSO ACROSS
EDUCATION AND HEALTH SECTOR
REPRESENTATIVES FOR SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA-
THROUGH THIS PROCESS
PARTICIPATING LEADERS FROM THE
CVT ACS AND SEE A PAGE THAT.
HAS SHARED HOW COLLABORATION
BETWEEN AGENCIES HAS BEEN
ELEVATED TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
INCLUDING INCREASED CREEK-
COMMUNICATION BOTH FORMAL AND
INFORMAL BETWEEN AGENCIES. OR
CALL THE HEALTH. AND THE
BUILDING A TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN AGENCY
STAFF THE HEALTH CARRY THE WORK
FORWARD IN MORE MEANINGFUL
WAYS. AND THESE RELATIONSHIPS
HAVE ALSO OPENED UP SPACE FOR
AGENCY LEADERS TO BUILD SHARED
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT HOW WILL BE
HEALTH RELATED WORK. HAPPENS
WITHINWITHIN EACH. WITHIN.
EACH STATE AGENCY CONTACT- ALSO
A REIMAGINE OF COMMUTING GAVE
WHETHER KEY OUT OF PROCESS THE
STATE AGENCIES CO CREATED AND
PARTICIPATED IN TRANSFORMATIVE
ENGAGEMENT PRACTICES. WITH THE
WORK GROUP THAT HELPED MAKE THE
VOICES OF THE WORKGROUP FRONT
AND CENTER THROUGHOUT THE
DURATION OF THE PROJECT.
ACTRESS IS ALSO HELP TO BUILD
TRUST BETWEEN THE STATE
AGENCIES AND WORKERS MEMBERS
AND TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STATE AGENCY LEADER AND
WORKERS NUMBERS TO SEE AND
UNDERSTAND ONE ANOTHER'S
EXPERIENCES IN CALIFORNIA'S
COMPLEX SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
SYSTEM. FINALLY THE WORKER
PROCESSES HELP TO BUILD SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY AND A PATH
TOWARD GREATER COHESION ACROSS
THE STATE AGENCIES AND
EDUCATION AND HEALTH SECTORS
FOR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH. AS
EVIDENCED IN THE WORKGROUP
FINAL REPORT. THESE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN
BUILT- THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
HAVE HELPED HOLDEN REPORTS BUT
SHARED PURPOSE FOR EXTENT
EXPANDING SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
IN CALIFORNIA. IN A COLLECTED-
COLLECTIVE AIM FOR MAKING SURE
OUR CHILDREN AND OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THE KIND
OF CARE THAT WILL HELP THEM
THRIVE. FAMILY MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE ABOUT THE
MEDICAL FOR STUDENTS CORPORATE
PROCESS RECOMMENDATIONS AND
OUTCOMES. AND GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO OUR NEXT SEGMENT- FOR
RESPONSES FROM THE STATE
AGENCIES FROM TAKE A PLAN
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH CARE FINANCING.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND DR DANIEL
LEVY DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE EQUITY BRANCH AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
S. TO THE TEAM FROM WEST AND
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THAT THE
NEXT PANEL MOMENTARILY BUT
BEFORE WE DO THAT I DO ANT TO
GOING TO QUESTIONS A LOT OF
TIMES AND HEARINGS WE HEALTH
QUESTIONS TO THE AND THAT'S
WHAT I KIND OF WANT TO
INTERJECT HIM. AS WE GO THROUGH
EACH PANEL BECAUSE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC- IF IT WASN'T
IMPORTANT WOULD HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE HERE THE MEMBERS- TO
COME BACK UP TO SACRAMENTO- SO
WITH THAT I DO WANNA KNOW THE
PRESENCE OF MAJORITY LEADER
**** AND IT- THE BUDGETS-
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO. ON
EDUCATION OF FINANCE- MISTER
MCCARTY WHO HAVE JOINED US.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US- I'VE-
OTHER A SEVEN MEMBER EARLIER
DIDN'T SEE WHY. UPON SIMILAR.
LEAVE HERE AS WELL- SO AGAIN- A
VERY IMPORTANT TO. I'VE GOT A
COUPLE QUESTIONS I'VE GOT TO
SEE RECOMMENDATIONS THANK YOU
CLEAR AND CONCISE- WELL SHARED
AND WELL PRESENTED THANK YOU-
EIGHT TO ME. SO I THINK WE NEED
TO GO BACK THE PROBLEM HERE%
BECAUSE I WANNA GET US LOST ON
THE PROBLEM AND AGAIN IT ISN'T
THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE IT'S REALLY ABOUT HOW
WE PROVIDE THE SERVICE AND BILL
BACK FOR THAT SERVICE HOW
DISTRICTS CAN BILL BACK SO THEY
ARE PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES-
SO I KEY IN HERE IS THE THEM
THE RECOMMENDATION NUMBER TWO
LOCAL AGENCY TRAINING AND
GUIDANCE THIS IS KEY- YESTERDAY
A CONVERSATION WITH- WITH ONE
OF- THE SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT I KNOW- AND I
SAID HEY ARE YOU DOING THIS
HAVE YOU BEEN DOING SAID YES
BUT IT'S VERY CUMBERSOME. HE
SAID IN A FEDERAL REGULATIONS
LAND THE STATE REGULATIONS AND
UNDER STATE REGULATIONS
EXAGGERATED JUST FEES SO IT'S A
REALLY TRAINING I THINK IT IS
KEY HERE IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
WE HAVE A LEAD AGENCY TO TRAIN
FOLKS WHY IT WOULD THEN I'M A
NATURAL IT WILL BE C. D. E. AND
I KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO- IF YOU
LIKE A RECOMMENDATION THREE WE
PUT MONEY IN THE BUDGET. A
RECENTLY TO ADDRESS NUMBER
THREE TO CREATE SOME
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS SO THAT
SCHOOLS CAN LEARN AND WE CAN
CREATE SOME TRAINERS TO THEN GO
OUT TO OTHER DISTRICTS AND
TRAIN THEM HOW TO PERFORM THIS
TYPE OF ACTIVITY BUT I'LL JUMP
A RECOMMENDATION BEFORE YOU
TALK ABOUT THE AUDIT THE L. A.
B. BOB ON IT- SUPPORT AT THE
WHAT I'VE BEEN HEARING IS
DISTRICTS BILL. THEY THEY
PERFORM THE SERVICE BILL FORD
AND THEY'LL GET AUDITED MAYBE
THREE YEARS LATER AND THEN 70%
OF THEIR MONEY THEY HAVE TO PAY
BACK- TO WHETHER THE FEDERAL
STATE GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T FOLLOW SOME SOME PROCESS
CORRECTLY AND I KNOW THAT
AUDITORS AUDIT THAT'S WHAT THEY
DO- THEY DON'T PERFORM THE
SERVICES ON THE GROUND SO THAT
MAYBE ONE OF OUR CHALLENGES
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THERE'S A DISCONNECT. BETWEEN
THE AUDIT AND THE ACTION ON THE
GROUND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
COULD COMMENT ON THAT I ASSUME
THIS WOULD BE THE AUDITOR THE
STATE AUDITOR THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD THAT THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO
ENGAGE IN THAT KIND OF EDUCATE
SOME FOLKS ON THE GROUND AS TO
HOW TO DO THIS BETTER SO THAT
THEY DON'T. AN AUDIT SOME YEARS
LATER I HAVE TO GIVE UP. A LOT
OF MONEY AND PAY PAY MONEY BACK.
THANK YOU- CHAIRED ON AFFORD.
THE QUESTION I ALL CERTAIN THE
NUMBING BY MIKE. TOM MY TO THE-
YOUR AS WELL- DID QUITE A OF
WORK WITH THE SUB. SUB GROUP-
FROM TH WORK GROUP THAT WAS
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE. THE
PROCESS BY WHICH ON THE AUDIT
TO KERR IS ACTUALLY UNIT WITHIN
THE H. C. S. SO. THEY ARE-
RESPONSIBLE FOR- BASICALLY
LOOKING OVER THESE-
EXPENDITURES THAT ARE BEING
CLAIMED. I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
PROGRAM DALY BACH AND ASKED MY
PROGRAMS ARE UNIQUELY DIFFERENT
FROM A LOT OF THE OTHER WAYS IN
WHICH- DOLLARS ARE DRAWN FROM
COUNT. FROM BY CALIFORNIA FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- WITH
REGARD TO MEDIC CAL IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M HAVING SAID
THAT ONE OF OUR OBSERVATIONS IS
THAT. THE DH CS IN PARTICULAR
I'M HAS REALLY BEEN WORKING
WITH A VERY STRANGE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES GIVEN WHAT'S
REQUIRED. I KIND OF PUT FORTH
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
ORDER TO- ESSENTIALLY VALIDATE
THAT THE COSTS THAT ARE BEING
CLEANED BY DISTRICTS ARE. ARE
DRAWN DOWN APPROPRIATELY. SO
THAT THE- AND RECOGNIZING THE
INVESTMENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE STATE- HAS MADE THROUGH
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS GOING TO CONTRIBUTE. TO
HELPING TO PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
TRAINING AND- THAT KIND OF
CAPACITY BUILDING SUPPORT TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WILL BE
NECESSARY SO THAT THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN. BOTH THAT
AUDIT OFFICE AND THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE- THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH THOSE THOSE
REVIEW PROCEDURES- IS MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT THAN THAN IT HAS BEEN
IN THE PAST. SO BUT I ALSO
WANTED BY THAI- TALK FOR ANY
OTHER OBSERVATIONS- TO THE- TO
THE TERRACE QUESTION. THANK YOU
JASON I MADE SO YOU CAN HEAR
DIRECTLY I'M ACTUALLY JUST PASS
IT OVER TO JACOB I SEE THAT
YOU'VE TURNED YOUR- CAMERA ON
ARE YOU AVAILABLE TO RESPOND TO
THIS FROM THE DCS RESPECTIVE.
HI MY NAME IS JAKE ONE ON
SYSTEM TO THE DIRECTOR HEALTH
CARE FINANCING HERE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. I'VE DEFINITELY HEARD
THE CONCERN RELATED TO AUDITING
REQUIREMENTS AND OUR ELITE.
PROGRAM AND HOW WE PROVIDE
TRAINING TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I THINK AS MISTER
WILLIS INDICATED. YELLING ABOUT
PROGRAM IS UNIQUE. THE FACT
THAT IS A POSSIBILITIES
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM AND USES
A CERTIFIED PUBLIC EXPENDITURE.
OF FUNDING MECHANISM TO DRAW
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS IN WHAT THAT
MEANS. IS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRES US TO AUDIT
ALL OF THE EXPECT SURE THAT WE
PAY TO COST. SO OBVIOUSLY THAT
IMPOSES A LARGE AUDIT BURDEN ON
THE PROVIDERS AND STATE TO
PROVIDE THOSE AUDITS HAVE
DEFINITELY HEARD. CONCERNS
RELATED TO THE TIMELINESS OF
THOSE AUDITS AND TRAINING
RELATED TO THAT. AS MENTIONED
IN THIS LATEST BUDGET ACT WE
RECEIVED- LIMITED TERM FUNDING
TO PROCURE A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANT CONTRACT TO HELP
PROVIDE TRAINING TO L. A. POPS.
ARE RELATED TO THE TO THE TO
LEN BASICALLY THAT'S OF THE L.
A. POP PROGRAM A LARGE
COMPONENT. COOL SYSTEMS WILL BE
FOCUSED ON. THE AUDITS AND WHAT
USED TO BE BROUGHT BROKERS NEED
TO BE MAINTAINED. AND HOW THOSE
AUDITS WILL BE. CONDUCTED BOB
THE OTHER. BOB ALSO THAT WE'VE
HEARD THROUGH THIS WORKGROUP IS
RELATED TO THE TIGHTENING OF
THOSE OUTLETS DEFINITELY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT A THREE YEAR
TIMELINE IS NOT IDEAL. IN TERMS
OF RECORD RETENTION AND
MAINTAINING THOSE DOCUMENTS.
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT OFF
PROGRAM. AND THEN ALLOWS DHS TO
ADDITIONAL YEARS TO. CIRCLE
BACK AND COMPLETE THOSE AUDITS
SO THAT IS- KIND OF WORTH THE
TIME LINE ORIGINATES FROM BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE OR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU I WANNA KNOW
THAT US SUMMER MEDINA HAS
JOINED US THANK YOU MISTER
MEDINA BUT WHAT LET ME LET ME
BACK I'LL JUST A GENERAL
QUESTION HOW DOES THIS WORK AT
THE SCHOOL SITE LEVEL THE
SERVICES PROVIDED. WHO ENTERS
IS THERE I THIS IS ALL DONE BY
MEDICAL CODES ARE SOME BILLING
CODES RIGHT MEDICAL BILLING
CODES. WHO WHO DOES THIS IS A
DOWNLOAD OF. THE SCHOOL SITE
LEVEL THEY WRITE THIS DOWN ON A
LOG AND THEN THEY SUBMITTED TO
THE DISTRICT OFFICE AND THEN.
THE BILL COMES OUT OF THE
DISTRICT OFFICE. YET SO. TO GO
BACK AND START AND THEN YOU CAN
TIME IF THAT'S OKAY- WHAT WE'VE
OBSERVED WITH MOST- SCHOOL
SYSTEMS IS THAT TYPICALLY THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR SCHOOL
SYSTEM WILL. TYPICALLY BUILD UP
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
REQUIRED TO COLLECT THE
INFORMATION THAT- IS. A PART OF
BASICALLY CLAIMING THE DOLLARS
FOR THESE CODES SO IF THERE IS
A SCHOOL BASED STAFF SAY IT'S
A- A PSYCHOLOGIST OR A SOCIAL
WORKER THAT IS ENGAGING IN SOME
BILLABLE ACTIVITY ON A SCHOOL
SAY. THERE'S A PROCESS THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL CREATE- AS
A AS A MEANS OF BASICALLY
GATHERING THAT INFORMATION FROM
THAT STAFF MEMBERS
SPECIFICALLY. NOW UNDER THAT%
THE MOST RECENT SPA AND JAKE UP
CAN GO INTO A BIT MORE DETAIL
ABOUT THIS IT HELPS TO.
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS A BIT
IN TERMS OF THE REQUIREMENT OF
THE INDIVIDUAL STAFF MEMBER TO
LOG THOSE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES.
THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT- ALLEY
A CAN THEN CLAIM- ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT THAT WE-
THAT. I THINK IS IMPORTANT TO
OBSERVE IS THAT. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COME IN ALL KINDS OF
SHAPES AND SIZES AND SO PRICKLY
FOR YOUR SMALLER SCHOOL
SYSTEMS- IT MAY NOT MAKE
PRACTICAL REASONABLE SENSE FOR
THEM TO BUILD THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THEIR CENTRAL OFFICE. RATHER IT
MIGHT BE CONSIDERATE TO LOOK TO
A REGIONAL OR INTERMEDIARY
ENTITY THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO
SCALE THOSE OPERATIONS. AND
ALLOW THE DISTRICT TO PASS A
LAW THAT HAPPENING. WE THERE
ARE EXAMPLES OF THAT- BUT WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF THE
PROPORTION OF DISTRICTS THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PROGRAM THERE IS THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW AND MANY OF
THOSE ARE SMALLER SYSTEMS-
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT JACOB- PLEASE WEIGH IN HERE
WITH- SOME OTHER OBSERVATIONS
ON. OKAY ALTHOUGH. OVERVIEW OF
HOW IT WORKS I THINK- DHS
CONTRACTS DIRECTLY WITH THE L.
A. ANY AND SO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. L. YANG MORE GLOBALLY
WILL SET UP THOSE PROCESS
WITHOUT THE LOCAL LEVEL. BUT
AGAIN HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS- WELL I YOU
KNOW I SEE ADVERTISERS LEARN
MEDICAL BILLING. RIGHT RIGHT
MEDICAL BILLING CODING AND ALL
THAT KIND OF THING SO I MEAN
THIS TELLS ME THAT THIS IS NOT
AN EASY THING TO DO. RIGHT IF
YOU'RE NOT TRAINED IN THIS AND
HAVE- THIS VISIT THE SKILL SET
NECESSARY TO REFORM THE SECTOR
YOU PROBABLY SHOULD BE DOING
IT. YEAH I'D PROBABLY CAN'T DO
IT RIGHT IS A MAYBE A LITTLE BY
THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON.
YEAH BUT I DO KNOW THAT IT'S
NOT LIKE. I COULD WALK IN AND
JUST. FILL OUT A FORM TO BE
DONE. IT DOES TAKE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TRAINING
AND WITH IT. THANK YOU WITH
THAT I DO WANT TO THANK YOU THE
OTHER MEMBERS HAVE A QUESTIONS
A DOCTOR WOULD. YEAH THANK YOU
I I'M JUST I'M JUST NOTE THAT-
I THOUGHT- MEDICINE HAVLAT'S
AKRON IS. AT THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE HAD LOTS ACRONYMS AND
THIS IS LIKE A WHOLE NEW WORLD
FOR ME. SO SO I APPRECIATE
THAT- I JUST WHAT I GUESS I
WOULD NOTE YOU KNOW FROM A FROM
A HEALTHCARE PERSPECTIVE. OF
THE WAY YOU BILL MEDICARE NOW
IS DIFFERENT WE DON'T.
TYPICALLY AS PROVIDERS GET
THESE. AUDITS LIKE THIS. WE
HAVE A HARD TIME GETTING PAID
FOR THE SERVICE UP FRONT.
THAT'S THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
AND SO. SO WE'RE NOT TYPICALLY
AUDITED AND THERE'S NOT
TYPICALLY CLAWBACKS. BUT JUST
BEING PAID SO THIS IS A VERY
DIFFERENT YSTEM THAN WHAT I'M
FAMILIAR WITH. AND I COULD SEE
THAT- IN MY OWN OFFICE WHEN WE
WERE DOING THIS- IT WAS NOT
UNUSUAL TO SAY. EVEN IT WITH
THE MOST DILIGENT
DOCUMENTATION. THAT THIRTY OR
40% OF OUR CLAIMS ARE REJECTED
BECAUSE WE MISTER. CROSSING A
TEAR DOT IN AND I. THAT'S HOW
DIFFICULT THE SYSTEM ITSELF- SO
I. I JUST WANTED YOU TO YOUR
RIGHT THE TRAINING FOR THIS IS.
IS A CHALLENGE IS A CHALLENGE
AND- WE ACTUALLY. THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM ACTUALLY. AT THAT'S AT
SOME POINT DID OFFER AND I
DON'T KNOW NOW I'M NOT
PRACTICING. TRAINING FOR PEOPLE
THAT WERE DOING BILLING FOR
SERVICES NOW THIS MAYBE THAT.
MAYBE THAT EXIST FOR THIS- FOR
THIS PROGRAM I'M NOT AWARE.
WHAT MIKE MY QUESTION IS- HOW
DID THE WORK GROUP DISCUSS ANY
ANYTHING RELATED TO TELEHEALTH
AND- OF THE GREATER USE OF
TELEHEALTH FOR. PROVIDING THE
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES. THANK
YOU MEMBER WOULD FOR YOUR
QUESTION I'LL I'LL LET T<c.cyan>.</c>
JUMP IN WITH A KIND OF INITIAL
RESPONSE AND THEN. BUT OTHERS
TO RESPOND T<c.cyan>. THANK YOU FOR</c>
THE QUESTION- SO I WANT TO JUST
TOUCH ON WHAT YOU. YOUR
COMMENT. BEFORE I ANSWER
QUESTIONS- WHICH IS TO SAY
THAT- I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER THREE IT
TALKS ABOUT SORT OF LEVERAGING
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT MEDICAID
ACCESS POINTS IN NOT ONLY AND
EXCLUSIVELY. THINKING ABOUT
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH SERVICES IN
TERMS OF WHAT SCHOOLS CAN BE
REIMBURSED THROUGH THE ALLEY
ABOUT BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A
DIFFICULT USING THE CERTIFIED
PUBLIC EXPENDITURE PROGRAM
TENDS TO BE REALLY DIFFICULT
FOR SCHOOLS. SO I WILL SAY THAT
THERE WAS A LOT OF FOCUS IN THE
WORKGROUP ON HOW CAN WE EXPAND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER TYPES
OF ACCESS POINTS. INCLUDING
THROUGH COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS STANDS IN MANAGED CARE
PLANS I JUST WANTED TO TOUCH ON
IT BRIEFLY- AND THEN THE
QUESTION ABOUT TELEHEALTH- SO
FOLKS TALK ABOUT THAT IN THE
BEGINNING. PARTICULARLY OF
CLOTHING AND WHEN THERE WAS
WHEN THERE WERE CHALLENGES WITH
TELEHEALTH. DH CS HAS PUT IN A
LOT OF EFFORT INTO LET JACOB
RESPOND TO THIS- BUT HAS PUT IN
PUT IN A LOT OF EFFORT EARLY ON
IN SCALING OUT TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. AND SO AS WE SORT OF
MOVE THROUGH THE WORKGROUP
PROCESS NOTHING RELATED TO
TELEHEALTH SORT OF. MADE IT
INTO THE FINAL REPORT OR AS A
RECOMMENDATION. AND THAT COULD
BE BECAUSE OF THE ACTIVITIES
THAT DHS WHAT THE GAME GAVE
STAND THROUGHOUT THE PAST TWO
YEARS SO I'LL LET. AND YOU WANT.
TO RESPOND TO THAT. YEAH SO
THANKS FOR THE- DOT WOULD AS
YOU KNOW WE HAD OUR- PCS THAT
ARE TELEHEALTH ONGOING.
PROPOSAL THOSE DISCUSSED IN
THIS. BOB POLICIES SUCH THAT
DIDN'T MOVE FORWARD. OBVIOUSLY
UNDER THE- CODE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES. WE'VE EXTENDED A
NUMBER OF TOTAL COAL WITH OUR
TELEHEALTH ABILITIES- WE'RE
CURRENTLY ENGAGED NONPROFITS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS OF. ONE
WHAT'S ABILITY SHOULD MOVE. AND
TO PROP SPACE- WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT- EXTENDING
TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITY AS FAR
TARGET CASE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
AND I'M LOOKING AT HOW COULD
WORK IN THE- LA POP TYPE
PROGRAM I THINK. THE WE EIGHT
CONSIDERATION WITH L. A. PAPPAS
IF THE STUDENTS AT HOME
RECEIVING. ADDITIONAL SERVICES
HOW DOES THE HOW DOES THE
TELEHEALTH SERVICE FOLLOW AND
SO DEFINITELY TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT DON'T HAVE ANY CONCRETE
INFORMATION INSTRUCTORS POINT
BUT THEY'LL DEFINITELY BE
INCLUDED IN. THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WE'RE HAVING AS
A- AS A STATE RELATED TO
TELEHEALTH TECHNOLOGIES. I
WOULD JUST AND JUST TO THE
CHAIR JUST ONE COMMENT ON THAT
I HAD EIGHTY TWO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN MY IN MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SO SOME OF THEM ARE
VERY SMALL SO THE IDEA THAT
EACH INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL DISTRICT
WITH SOME HAVE TO CREATE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE HERE. TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THESE SERVICES IS IT
GOING TO WORK AND A LOT OF
TIMES THE KIDS AND SOME OF THE
SMALLER DISTRICTS HAVE HIGHEST
NEEDS. AND ONE OF MY COUNTIES
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
ACES IN THE STATE IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY. AND SO THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO FIND A WAY TO.
CREATE A SYSTEM WHERE YOU COULD
ACTUALLY USE THE- TELEHEALTH
FOR SOME OF THESE AS A
COMBINATION FOR MULTIPLE
DISTRICTS POSSIBLY CERTAINLY
AROUND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
WOULD BE REALLY REALLY VALUABLE
INSTEAD OF REINVENTING THE
WHEEL FOR EIGHTY TWO DISTRICTS.
SO SO I MIGHT URGE I URGE IN
THE FUTURE DCS AND OTHERS TO
CONSIDER THAT- CONSIDER THOSE
KINDS OF MODELS BECAUSE-
OTHERWISE WE LEAVE A WHOLE LOT
OF KIDS BEHIND. EIGHTY TO
DESTROY. WOW OKAY- MISS WALDRON
THAT'S LIKE HUNDRED SOME BOARD
THAT'S ALL ACTUALLY IT'S THESE
AFTER UNDERSTOOD THIS WATER.
THANK YOU IN CHAIR- YOU KNOW
DOCTOR WOULD BRINGS UP A GOOD
POINT THE KIND OF SIDEWAYS INTO
WHAT I WAS GOING TO ASK- YEAH
MY DISTRICT IS. EXTREMELY RURAL
AS YOURS IS AND THERE IS A BIT
WITH THE INTERNET BROADBAND IS
IN A WOULD BE A LUXURY THAT YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE AND- YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW- OUR SCHOOLS
ABLE TO TRANSMIT THEIR DATA AND%
INFORMATION OVER THE INTERNET
OR IS IT STILL ALL DONE BY
PAPER- YOU KNOW. WE WOULD DO IT
WOULD JUST MENTIONED ABOUT IN
THE DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
TRYING TO WORK ON- BETTER
COHESION. AS YOU'RE INTEGRATING
BETWEEN COUNTY HEALTH PLANS
MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER. YOU
KNOW ENTITIES THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN THIS. BUT HE WITH THE GOAL
OF BETTER COHESION. HOW CAN
THIS WHOLE THING BE STREAMLINED
I MEAN I'M ASSUMING BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IDEAL AND- MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
AND- YOU KNOW WE WERE AMAZED TO
DISCOVER I THINK IT WAS YOUR
COMMITTEE A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
WHERE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ANNOUNCED TO US THAT.
THEY DON'T SET THE RATES. IN
SUBSTANCE USE THIS WAS BACK A
FEW YEARS AGO. FOR SO EACH
COUNTY WAS DIFFERENT SO I'M
ASSUMING IN THIS CASE EACH
COUNTY IS DIFFERENT HELD THEIR
HANDLING OF HOW THEY'RE
PROCESSING IT HOW. THEY WORK
WITH THE DIFFERENT HEALTH
PLANS. I MEAN I I'M JUST
ASSUMING THAT. SO WOULD I MEAN
BETTER COHESION WOULD BE A GOAL.
IS THERE EFFORT OR IS THERE
SOME WAY YOU CAN BE
STANDARDIZED. SO EVERY COUNTY
ISN'T RECREATING THE WHEEL OR
YOU KNOW EACH LITTLE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF THAT AND IT COULD
BE MORE- INTERNET BASED OR YOU
KNOW USER FRIENDLY- BECAUSE I
THINK IF THE MORE WE CAN
STANDARDIZE IT THE MORE WE CAN
STREAMLINE THE MORE EFFICIENT
THE USE OF FUNDS WILL BE AND
THE MORE KIDS CAN GET ACCESS.
SO I JUST I ON. THE WITH THAT
COME OUT IN THIS IN THIS IN THE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT YEAH
THANK YOU MEMBER WALDRON AND-
ALL ASK MISTER LAMB TO CHIME IN
ON THIS ONE AS WELL I THINK
THAT. IN PARTICULAR YOU POINTED
TO RECOMMENDATION THREE- AND I
DO THINK THAT THAT IS A SPACE
IN WHICH SOME OF THAT
EXPERIMENTATION AND SOME OF
THAT- INNOVATION COULD TAKE
PLACE TO IN PARTICULAR WHAT
YOU'RE- REFERRING TO AND WHAT
MEMBER WOULD ALSO REFERENCED
WAS- THIS NOTION OF BASICALLY
ECONOMIES OF SCALE RIGHT LIKE
IT'S INEFFICIENT FOR THE STATE
TO INVEST RESOURCES WHEN YOU
HAVE SUCH SMALL ENTITIES. THAT
ARE HAVING TO BUILD UP
INFRASTRUCTURE OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AND THERE ARE
ENTITIES- LIKE COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH OTHER. STATE INVESTMENTS
THAT HAVE GONE INTO REGIONAL
ACTIVITIES THAT COULD PROVIDE
SOME OF THAT RISK THAT
STRUCTURE AND A RECOMMENDATION
THREE AND THAT WAY OFFERS A
CHANCE TO REALLY KIND OF STUDY
THAT AND UNDERSTAND HOW TO. HOW
TO SCALE THAT QUICKLY AND WITH
THAT WITH EFFECTIVENESS THE
OTHER RECOMMENDATION THAT I
WOULD POINT TO HIS
RECOMMENDATION TO- AND THAT'S
REALLY AROUND SOME OF THE
TARGETED TRAINING AND GUIDANCE
TO ELEAZAR- WITH THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS YOU ALL
KNOW- THERE WERE SEVERAL
INVESTMENTS THAT WERE MADE INTO
THE SPACE- AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S THAT'S- THAT'S FAIRLY
NEW FOR CALIFORNIA WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THOSE KINDS OF INVESTMENTS
BEFORE- IN WHICH- THEIR STATE
DOLLARS THAT ARE COMING ALONG
SIDE. THE MARGIN OF THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS TO BASICALLY OPERATE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE VALLEY DOT
BOB AND I SMALL. SO IT CREATES
A CHANCE FOR AGENCIES LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN. THOSE I'M ON
THE GROUND THAT ARE HAVING TO
OPERATE THE STRUCTURES. TO
CREATE MORE EFFECTIVENESS
CREATE MORE EFFICIENCY FROM-
THOSE KINDS OF TRAINING AND
SUPPORT SO. SO REALLY
RECOGNITION TO IN THREE KIND OF
HELP TO ADDRESS SOME PART
NUMBER WALDRON- PART YOUR
QUESTION BUT- MISTER LAMB WHAT
WHAT ELSE WOULD YOU. YOU ADD TO
THAT. YEAH I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT. D. L. A. BOB PROGRAM HAS
TRANSITIONED MARC TO-
ELECTRONIC BASIS IN THE LAST
YEAR TO WHEN NO LONGER
REQUIRING PHYSICAL HARM
SIGNATURES ON DOCUMENTS ARE
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN EASE SOME
OF THOSE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS- I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
UP THE RUNOFF PROGRAM THEY
NOTICE ONE OF OUR OTHER BIG CP
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE SO IT IS
ALSO CURRENTLY AUDITS COSTS
WE'RE LOOKING TO CHANGE THAT IN
OUR- OF THIS PART OF OUR
KILLING PROPOSAL. BEYOND
LOOKING. AT L. A. POP I THINK.
WHAT IMPORTANT A WRECK
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE. IS THAT
THE ONLY BOXER IS LOOKING FOR
PURPOSE TRYING FEDERAL
REIMBURSED. FOR SERVICES
PROVIDING SCHOOLS BUT THERE ARE
CERTAINLY TECHNICAL LIMITATIONS
TO HOW THAT CAN BE ROLLED OUT
ONE OF WHICH AND- PRESS MAINLY
IS NOT BOTHERING TO COST. AND
SO YOU'LL SEE YOUR IN DIFFERENT
AREAS OF THE STATE IT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPENSIVE TO
SERVICE FOR. AND A FISHERIES
WHICH MEANS THOSE THERE IS A
BAR BECAUSE IT COSTS MORE
WHEREAS OTHER AREAS WHERE IT'S
LESS EXPENSIVE. GET REIMBURSED
THAT THAT LOWER RATE- UP. IN MY
TESTIMONY I'LL GO TO A COUPLE
OF INITIATIVES THAT WEREN'T
GOOD IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET LIKE ARE LOOKING AT. HOW
DO WE INCREASE SCHOOL BASED
SERVICES AND REIMBURSEMENT. OF
LA BOB AND THROUGH THOSE
OPTIONS I THINK. WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO STANDARDIZE THE
PROCESS AND KIND OF GIVE YOU
SOME OF THOSE ADMINISTRATORS.
GET AWAY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN SPECIFIC
TO L. A. BACH. SO THIS IS
DEFINITELY A TOPIC THAT WE ARE
EXPLORING RIGHT BEACH DOESN'T
HAVE. A LOT OF A LOT OF FUNDING
GOING. TOWARDS IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
I THINK ONE OF THINGS I'M
STRUGGLING HERE WITH IS IT THE
PERSON WHO BILLS THAT NEED TO
CHANGE THEIR PRACTICES OR IS
THAT THE AUDITOR. THE NEEDS
CHANGE THEIR PRACTICES IT OR IS
IT SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN BUT
WE'LL HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
LATER A DOCTOR ARAMBULA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE STRUCTURE
AND- I WANT TO GO BACK TO ONE
OF THE COMMENTS REGARDING
SHARED OWNERSHIP AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE- PLACING THE
CHILD AT. THE CENTER I DON'T
WANT TO SOLELY TO BE A
RESPONSIBILITY OF CDP. BUT FOR
US TO RECOGNIZE THAT WITHIN
MEDIC CAL WE HAVE
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER
FEDERALLY PST T. TO PROVIDE
CERTAIN COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES.
AND WITH THAT WE ARE REQUIRED
TO GUARANTEED TO THE- FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING THE COMPREHENSIVE
SERVICES. THAT RIGHT NOW IS
BEING DONE THROUGH A PATCHWORK
OF OUR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES ARE. COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS AND OTHER MANAGED
CARE PLANS. AND IT REALLY DOES
REQUIRE OVERSIGHT AND
COORDINATION FROM THE STATE AND
I'M LOOKING FORWARD. TO HEARING
TO FORMALIZE THAT RELATIONSHIP.
SO THAT WE CAN ULTIMATELY HELP
THE CHILD WHO THAT THE CENTER
OF THIS. FOR US TO FOCUS ON THE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN BOTH
CURRENTLY AND HISTORICALLY LEFT
BEHIND. IS A WAY IN WHICH WE
CAN DEMONSTRATE. THAT WE ARE
MAKING A DIFFERENCE AND
FOCUSING ON DISPARITIES. AND SO
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION WHICH TYPES OF
AREAS YOU BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON. WHICH SITES OR-
LOCALITIES WE BE AT. SINCE IT'S
BEEN BROUGHT UP WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S AT THE DISTRICT LEVEL OR
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. WHERE THERE ARE
ADVANTAGES FOR US TO BE
PARTNERING WITH MANAGED CARE
PLANS ON A COUNTY LEVEL SINCE
THEY ULTIMATELY WILL ALSO BE
TAKEN CARE. OF THESE CHILDREN
WHO BECOME ADULTS LATER ON IN
LIFE. THAT I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO REALLY HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE CONVERSATION. AND
SO I'M GRATEFUL THAT- RIGHT NOW
WE CAN. ACKNOWLEDGE OUR SHARED
OWNERSHIP AND WORK ON- THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE AT THE CENTER.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO HEAR
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION NEXT
REGARDING- HOW WE CAN WORK ON
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS NOW. IF
YOU'LL ALLOW ME SINCE I TALKED
ABOUT BEING IN THE CLASSROOM
EARLIER THIS MONDAY I MET WITH
MY- COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT THIS
WEEK AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
AND APPRECIATE. ALL THE WORK
THAT OUR SUPERINTENDENTS ARE
DOING ALL THE WORK THAT OUR
EDUCATORS ARE DOING RIGHT NOW
TO KEEP. KIDS IN CLASSROOMS WE
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE STRESS
THAT. THOSE IN EDUCATION ARE
UNDER AND- THE TIMING OF THIS
CONVERSATION BUT WE CANNOT LOSE
SIGHT OF THE IMPORTANCE. THAT
THIS CONVERSATION HAS FOR US AS
A STATE. AND THAT ULTIMATELY BY
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION RIGHT
NOW EVEN IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC OF THE CENTURY WE CAN
HELP OUT MANY OF THOSE. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SO- MY COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT WAS HIGHLIGHTING
HOW DIFFICULT THEY ARE HAVING
RIGHT NOW JUST KEEPING TEACHERS
IN CLASSROOMS. AND- MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE SCHOOL BUS DRIVERS
WHO ARE SHOWING UP EVERY DAY
AND SO I KNOW THESE
CONVERSATIONS ARE HARD BUT BY
WORKING ON- WE CAN PULL DOWN
MORE FEDERAL RESOURCES AND HELP
KIDS WHO NEED IT THE MOST AND
SO THAT'S WHY I'M GRATEFUL- TO
BE HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS
AND HOPE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WHO HAS THE NEXT
PANEL CAN ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I PROPERTY.
THANK YOU DR RANDALL ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL.
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE PANEL JUST HAS ONE
SHORT ONE IS THERE ANY STATE OR
STATES THAT WE SHOULD LOOK TO.
WHO DO THIS BETTER THAN
CALIFORNIA TODAY OF EARLY ON IN
THE PROCESS WE DID- LOOK AT A
SERIES OF OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE BEEN ENGAGING IN THESE
ACTIVITIES- ONE OF THE
CONSISTENT STATES THAT COMES UP
PRICKLY WHEN THINKING ABOUT
THIS REGIONAL LYSED
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN- I WILL REMIND THE
PANEL THAT THE SIZE OF MICHIGAN
ISNO LARGER THAN THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES SO OUR- SCALING
CHALLENGES. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE OF WELL EXCEED
THAT OF WHAT WE WERE LOOKING
OUT AND OTHER STATES BOB BUT
WHEN YOU CREATE THAT
EQUIVALENCE ACROSS- STATE LIKE
MICHIGAN TO- REGIONS LIKE L. A.
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE- THERE MAY
BE SOME- EFFECTIVE PRACTICES
THAT COULD BE LEVERAGED- WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF THE RULES THAT-
BOTH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
MINISTRATION DH CS AND CITY OF
SET OUT FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
RIGHT AND IT DOESN'T MEAN THERE
COULD BE SOME MIX AND MATCH
WHERE AND- LIKE IN LA UNIFIED
WE DO IT ON THEIR OWN BUT MAYBE
A MODOC CETERA- THERE WOULD BE
SOME TRI COUNTY EFFORT OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT OR SOME
REGIONAL APPROACH TO THANK YOU
WITH THAT WILL GO TO- AND PANEL
NUMBER TWO. I THANK YOU TO THE-
WHAT WEST AT. TWO EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU WELL DONE WELL DONE.
IN OF THE SECOND. OUR SECOND
INCLUDES. FROM THIS. AGENCIES
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. BOTH
ARE SPEAKING VIA TELECONFERENCE
TODAY VIDEO CONFERENCE- FIRST
UP IS JACOB LAMB FROM DH CS-
FOLLOWED BY DR DANIEL LEVY FROM
CD. ARE YOU A RECEIPT WHEN
READY WE'VE ALREADY HEARD ABOUT
FROM THE FROM MISTER LEVITT
PROCEED PLEASE. THANK YOU WANT
TO ENSURE MEMBERS AAIN MY NAME
IS JACOB LAMB I CONSISTENT IF
YOU DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
FINANCING- OR SERVICES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT IN THE WORK
GROUP FOR THEIR EFFORTS-
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS REPORT
AND THANK YOU TO BUY STUFF FOR
PRESENTED THE WORKGROUP
RECOMMENDATIONS- DHS WAS A
MEMBER OF THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE IN THIS
WORLD DCS PROVIDED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND PROGRAMMATIC
INFORMATION TO WORK GROUP
MEMBERS. PURSUANT TO SB SEVENTY
FIVE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
CONTAINED WITHIN THIS REPORTER
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING CORONATION
AN EXPANSION OF ACCESS TO
AVAILABLE FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
MEDICAID SERVICES IN A SCHOOL
SETTING. RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
DEVELOPER GROUP MEMBERS. THE
EXCESS RECOGNIZES THAT SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CARE IS A POWERFUL
TOOL REFUSING HEALTH EQUITY
AMONG CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS
WHO UNJUSTLY EXPERIENCED A
DISPARITIES. IN OUTCOMES SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE ETHNICITY
OR FAMILY INCOME. BUILDING UP
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM OF HEALTH IS
A DYNAMIC SOLUTION TO THE
INEQUALITIES THAT MANY CHILDREN
CALIFORNIA FACED. IN THIS NAME
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS DECSS
MADE A NUMBER OF INVESTMENTS
THAT AIM TO IMPROVE
COORDINATION OF BENEFITS
BETWEEN MANAGED CARE PLANS. AND
SCHOOL AFFILIATED PROVIDERS.
SIMILAR TO THE RECOMMENDATION
CONTAINED IN THIS REPORT THESE
INVESTMENTS THE CONGRESS WILL
BASED HEALTH CARE BY EXPANDING
ACCESS TO THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
BILLING OPTIONS PROGRAM ALSO
KNOWN AS ALI BABA. AND BUILDING
ALTERNATIVE AVENUES FOR L. YES
TO ACCESS MEDICAID
REIMBURSEMENT. STARTING WITH L.
A. BACH APRIL TWENTY TWENTY CMS
APPROVED STATE PLAN AMENDMENT
FIFTY INVESTED ZERO TWO ONE
WHICH EXPANDED L. A. BOB BY
ADDING NEW SERVICE
PRACTITIONERS AND SERVICES TO
THE PROGRAM. AND EXPAND THE
POPULATION COVERAGE MORE
PROBABLY INCLUDE ANY CHILD
ENROLLED IN MEDI CAL WITH
INDIVIDUAL CARE PLAN. DO YOU
THESE CHANGES WILL EXPAND
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM BY
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SERVICES. SOME
EXAMPLES OF NEW SERVICES GROUP
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
NUTRITIONAL SERVICES AWESOME
EXAMPLES OF NEW PER ACTIVATION
ORDERS INCLUDES THE SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY ASSISTANTS.
PRIOR TO THIS AMENDMENT L. A.
BACH WAS FAIRLY NARROW IN ITS
SCOPE AND FOCUSED ON CHILDREN
WITHOUT A P. R. I. S. S. P.
PLAN. OF YOU RECEIVING SERVICES
AND SCHOOLS. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE BUDGET ACT ALSO
INCLUDED A PETITIONS TO EXPAND
IMPROVE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CARE BROUGH UP THE BUDGET
INCLUDED LIMITADA FOR DHS TO
HIRE A CONTRACTOR TO HELP
IMPLEMENT THE EXPANSION OF THE
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RELATED TO THE STATE
I'M NOT. THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL FOCUS ON THE
EXPANDED BENEFITS THE CHANGE IN
ELIGIBILITY AND INCLUDES
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
EXPECTED PRACTITIONERS
ADDITIONALLY AS MENTIONED IN MY
EARLIER TESTIMONY THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL FOCUS ON THE
AUDITING PROCESS AND
REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL BE
IMPOSED THAT ARE IMPOSED ON THE
SCHOOLS ARE PARTICIPATING IN
THE- PROGRAM. AS PART OF THIS
DO YOU SEE THIS IS WORKING.
WITH OUR AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS TEAM TO SEE.
WHAT TYPE OF TRAINING WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO SCHOOLS AND REACHING
OUT TO SCHOOLS AND SEE TO SEE.
HOW THAT TRAINING CAN BEST BE
ARE DELIVERED TO THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS ARE PARTICIPATING
IN THE PROGRAM. MORE BROADLY
RELATED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DCS
SIXTY WAS RECENTLY APPROVED
FUNDING TO ESTABLISH A STATE
WIDE CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR
EVERY YOUNG PERSON HAS ACCESS
TO HELP WHEN THEY NEED IT WHERE
THEY SPEND THEIR TIME IN
SCHOOLS. THIS MEANS TEACHERS
AND STAFF FOR TRYING TO
RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO NEED HELP
DROP IN SERVICES ARE EASILY
AVAILABLE AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN OR NEAR SCHOOLS
CONNECT TO A BROADER NETWORK OF
SERVICES SUPPORTED BY. APRIL
HEALTH PLANS AND COUNTIES.
REALLY WHAT THIS IS FOCUSING ON
EXPANDING THE RECESSES SCHOOL
BASED FOOTPRINT BEYOND JUST THE
ONLY A TOP PROGRAM. WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE
LIMITATIONS AROUND ONLY ABOUT.
HOW DO WE OPEN UP NEW AVENUES
FOR- SCHOOLS AND PLANS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
STUDENTS AND CHILDREN. SO THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS WOULD LIKE
TO FOCUS ON THE TWO FOLLOWING
INVESTMENTS. FIRST WE EVER
STUDENT BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INCENTIVE PROGRAM SO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDED
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THREE YEARS FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM IS A MASCARA
CENTIPEDES ARTICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE INFRASTRUCTURE
PARTNERSHIP AND CAPACITY
STATEWIDE. FOR SCHOOL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. AT
THE PAYMENTS WILL BE MADE
SMASHED YOUR PLANS. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF. TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE STUDENTS RECEIVING
PREVENTATIVE AND EARLY
INTERVENTION BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES PROVIDED BY SCHOOL
AFFILIATED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS BY IMPROVING
COORDINATION COLLABORATION
BETWEEN MASTER PLANS. SCHOOL
AFFILIATED PROVIDERS. AND
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANS.
THE DEFENSE WILL BE MAY
EFFECTIVE THAT MEDICARE
REIMBURSED SERVICE PROVIDED
CHILDREN USED TO REDUCE HEALTH
EQUITY GAPS AFTER SERVICES
PROVIDED TO CHILDREN YOUTH
LOOKING TRANSITION ARE HOMELESS
OR INVOLVED IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. REALLY THIS
PROPOSAL IS FOCUSED ON.
BUILDING THAT PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE SCHOOLS AND THE
MANAGED CARE PLAN SO THAT WE
GET AWAY FROM THE AUDITING AND
COST BASED PRINCIPLES OF THE L.
A. BACH PROGRAM. AND SPEAKING
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER AROUND WITH
COMMENTS. THE SCHOOLS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING A
FREE APPROPRIATE EDUCATION TO
THEIR STUDENTS BALLER MANAGED
CARE PLANS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING-
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS TO THEIR
MEMBERS. SO REALLY THIS
PROPOSAL IS LOOKING AT. THAT
BREAKING DOWN THE SILOS BETWEEN
THESE TWO SYSTEMS AND MAKING
SUTTER TALKING TO ONE ANOTHER
AND PROVIDING SERVICES IN A
COORDINATED FASHION. SO BEYOND
THIS PROPOSAL THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET THAT INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL THREE POINT THREE
BILLION TO TRANSFER TO
TRANSFORM CALIFORNIA'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM FOR
CHILDREN YOU. TO AN INNOVATIVE
EXPANSION SYSTEM ALL CHILDREN
ARE ROUTINELY SCREENED
SUPPORTED AND SEARCH FOR
MERGING EXISTING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS. THE SERVICES WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO ALL CHILDREN
YOUTH NOT JUST THOSE IN THE OLD
A MEDIC CAL. SPECIFIC TO SCHOOL
RULER FOR ITS CONSISTENT WITH
SB SEVENTY FIVE THE CHILDREN
YOU'VE BEEN HEALTH INITIATIVE
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING
COMPONENTS. BARBARA FIFTY
MILLION FOR SCHOOLING TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICE
CAPACITY INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS
PROVIDED DIRECTLY TO COUNTIES
TRIBAL ENTITIES SCHOOLS LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HEALTH CARE SERVICE
PLANS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORTING
ONGOING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT
SERVICES ON OR NEAR CAMPUS. OF
CBO'S WILL FILL A CRITICAL ROLE
CONNECTING PROVIDING REFERRALS
FOR HIGHER LEVEL FOLLOW UP
SERVICES. WITH THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS. SO BASED ON
FEEDBACK WE RECEIVED THROUGH
THE SB SEVENTY FIVE PROCESS
AND- I'LL BE ROLLING OUT THIS
PROPOSAL. THERE ARE NEEDS TO BE
CAPACITY BUILT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO PROVIDE THESE SERVICES
IN ORDER FOR ANY- TRANSITION OR
IMPLEMENTATION OF EXPANDED
SERVICES TO BE SUCCESSFUL SO
REALLY THIS BLACK MARKET TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IS FOCUSED ON
BUILDING THOSE SERVICES. ARE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL STATEWIDE IS
THAT WE HAVE A NETWORK OF
PROVIDERS WERE THERE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES. TO THESE CHILDREN.
BEYOND THAT HUNDRED TWO MILLION
FORTY FIVE MILLION OVER THE
NEXT YEAR NEXT THREE YEARS WILL
BE USED TO BUILD UPON THE
EXISTING KHALKHAL CRISIS
COUNSELING AD SUPPORT
SERVICES. THIS INVESTMENT AND
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS. STUDENTS PARENTS
AND STAFF WILL BENEFIT FROM
TRAINING TOOLS TO ASSIST WITH
THEIR MENTAL WELLBEING. AND
FINALLY THE LAST COUPLE OF THE
CHINESE PEOPLE NOT FINISHED IF
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT. IS
REQUIRING HEALTH PLANS. NO
SOONER THAN JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TO PROVIDE
SCHOOLING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND REIMBURSABLE
AFFILIATE PROVIDERS. BASED ON A
FEW SCHEDULE ESTABLISHED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE. SO THIS IS
A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THIS
INITIATIVE AGAIN WELL BEYOND
THE JUST MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND LOOKING AT ALL. SURE
STATEWIDE. PROVIDING A
STATEWIDE FEE SCHEDULES THAT
SCHOOLS ARE PROVIDING THESE
SERVICES. CAN BE REIMBURSED FOR
THE SERVICES. OF THE LAST
INITIATIVE I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT IS UCS IS ONGOING
MEDICAL MANAGED CARE PLAN WITH
REPURPOSE YOUR- BOB WE ARE
CURRENTLY ENGAGED EVERY
PROCUREMENT PROCESS FOR ALL
COMMERCIAL MANAGED CARE PLANS
THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS ALLOWS
THE DEPARTMENT TO EVALUATE ITS
EXISTING CONTRACTS WITH MANAGED
CARE PLANS. IDENTIFY EXISTING
OR NEW EXPECTATIONS FOR PLANS
AND THEN ENTER INTO NEW
CONTRACTS WITH A NEW OR
EXISTING CLIENTS. AS PART OF
THIS PROCESS DCS IS ABOUT
WAITING TO EXISTING CONTRACTUAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO COORDINATE WITH LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. DCS SIX
TRUMBULL STRICT REQUIREMENTS
FOR MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
COLLABORATE AND COORDINATE WITH
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE MEMBERS
INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PLAN OR
THE INDIVIDUAL FAMILY SERVICE
PLAN. THE SEATTLE WORK WITH
PLANSON A BUST OPERATIONAL
READINESS PROCESS TO ENSURE
THAT THE PLAN TO MEET THE
EXTENSIVE CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS AND DEMONSTRATE
THEIR ABILITY TO FOSTER LOCAL
RELATIONSHIPS TO BETTER SERVE
OUR MEDICAL MEMBERS. ACS
BELIEVES THESE NEW REQUIREMENTS
RESULT IN IMPROVED HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN YOUTH AND
THESE REQUIREMENTS WILL GO INTO
EFFECT BEGINNING JANUARY. ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. SO BE ONLY
THING. WE'D ALSO LIKE TO READ.
THE THESE CHANGES NOT BE SO.
ABOUT PARTNERING WITH. THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. YES
ASSEMBLY FIVE PURPOSE
FACILITATE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN DHS STD. WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED REGULAR CHECK INS
BETWEEN LEADERSHIP AND STAFF AT
BOTH DEPARTMENTS. AS NOTED IN
SOME OF THE MEMBERS COMMENTS.
HEALTHCARE IS AN INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX AND TECHNICAL AREA
WHICH IS MRRORED IN THE
EDUCATION ROUTE. WITHOUT
COMBINING EXPERTISE FROM BOTH
AREAS WILL NOT BE SUCCESSFUL
MISCHIEF'S THAT I'VE OUTLINED
ABOVE. SPECIFICALLY DHS IS
WORKING WITH CD ON
COLLABORATION ON TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CONTRACT FOR THE
ONLY POP EXPANSION. ARTISTIC
WITH THE CONTRACT I REFERENCED
EARLIER IN MY TESTIMONY-
WORKING WITH CD EACH IDENTIFY
STAKEHOLDERS AND PROVIDING
EXPERTISE IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE INCENTIVE ACTIVITIES ON THE
STUDENT BEHAVIOR HOLDEN SUCH
PROGRAM. YOUR WORKING WITH
CITIES COPING TEN ABOUT GUY. WE
HAVE BY MONTHLY L. A. BOSTON
MEET AND COLLABORATE ON
TRAINING PROGRAM UPDATES. AND
WE HAVE ONGOING REGULAR
CONSULTATION ACROSS DEPARTMENTS
ON POLICY DEVELOPMENT AND
PROGRAMMING. ULTIMATELY THE
EFFORTS RELATED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SB SEVENTY
FIVE REPORT HAVING FORMED
INSISTED DCS AND DEVELOPING A
PRIORITIZING THE ABOVEMENTIONED
INITIATIVES. MANY OF THOSE
DISCARDED PRO PROPOSALS FALL
PROBABLY WITHIN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS CONTAINED
WITHIN THE REPORT AND YOU JUST
AS EXCITED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
IMPLEMENTING THESE INITIATIVES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- AND IS
JUST A COMMA QUICKLY I
APPRECIATE YOUR DESIRE TO SEE
IT ELEAZAR HAVE BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH SOME OF THE
MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATIONS
WHETHER THEY BE IN MEDICAL OR
NOT BUT I STILL THINK WE CAN
EVADE RECOMMENDATION NUMBER
FOUR WHICH TALKS ABOUT THE
AUDITING PROCESS I THINK THAT'S
KEY HERE YOU NEED TO BE MUCH
MORE EDUCATION ON THE AUDITING
PROCESS BECAUSE I THINK WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS PEOPLE ARE RUNNING
TROUBLED IN THE AUDITING
PROCESS OR THE RUNNING FROM THE
AUDITING PROCESS. AND THAT
MEANS NOT PROVIDING SERVICES
THEY JUST SHUT DOWN THEIR
EFFORTS BECAUSE OF THE AUDITING
PROCESS SO WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON THAT SEASON CHANGE
THERE- MORE COMMUNICATION MORE
EDUCATION ON THE AUDITING
PROCESS IS AGAIN IF YOU LOOK AT
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE FOR WHICH
WE SPOKE TO THE LAST PANEL THAT
IS KEY- THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ONTO- MISTER DOCTOR
DANIEL LEE AND HIS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DR LEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENCE HERE TODAY MAY
PERCEIVE AN ARTICLE PROBLEM
GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS THAT
THE DATA LEON TO GET THE
SUPERINTENDED OF EQUITY. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ACT HAD TO TAKE A
MOMENT BECAUSE BASED ON YOUR
QUESTIONS IN RESPONSE TO THE
CHANGE ON MY. TOP COMPLIANCE.
WHICH WAS HELPFUL. A BIG- IT'S
A ONE OF ONE TO DO WITH SORT OF.
BACK FOR A MOMENT BECAUSE I AM
LIKE I SAID ARENA TO DEPEND.
HIM AS I CAN HELP WITH SOMEBODY
QUESTIONS- BECAUSE I. THE CHEN
REEF HOW ARE WE DO. SO DE
TALKING BIT ABOUT- IN HER FOR
JAKE OF- SORT OF SOME OF THE
POINTS INTO OF PART. SO ONE OF
TO SEE OUR- THE- FOR THE STATE.
AROUND SB SEVEN FIVE BECAUSE
THEY JUMP STARTED TO. LIKE
AGENCIES AND I THINK THAT WAS A
POOR- REDUCING THE SILENCE I
WANNA ALSO CHAMPION R. I. C.
AND I. SO FROM SUPERINTENDENT
WE ARE WITH THE TODAY- CELL
MORTGAGE SHE LED THIS PER- FOR.
TO GET TO THIS POINT- WITH THE
REPORTS BUT WHAT ARE WE TO HIGH.
IS REALLY- SO OF THE POINTS
THAT YOU MAY. AND OF HOW TO
SWIM ME START WITH THE ALREADY.
AND THEN KIND OF GO. I'M NOT
ONE OF THE ABOUT THE NOTION OF
WHERE WE HADN'T. OF SCHOOL
TRANSFORMATION AS A CONTEXT AND
THEN THINK ABOUT- SORT OF HAD A
MEDICAL BILLING AND SORT OF
THIS BEHAVIOR HEALTH INVESTMENT
IS. FITTING INTO THE SCHOOL
TRANSFORMATION MOVEMENT- THAT
WOULD IN AND THEN TALK ABOUT
THE PRACTICAL PIECES ONLY UP TO
THE MINUTE SOMEBODY SOME REAL
QUICK HAIRLIKE AND BULLET
POINTS. TO SORT OF HIGHLIGHT
THAT SO GETTING TO THE- SORRY.
DIDN'T THE- ISSUES AROUND THE
AUDIENCE WHEN I WAS WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT I THINK YOU SOMETIME
HOW. THIS IS IT. AROUND BILLING
CHANGES AUDIT IS CHANGES IT'S A
COMBINATION AND I THINK THAT'S
THE REASON WE NEED TO HAVE CD
EITHER PART OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FIGURE THIS OUT. WHICH
I AND I GUESS AS I'M A LICENSE
AS A CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST SO
THAT I DO THE MENTAL HEALTH
BILL AND SO AND I'M GOING TO
THESE AUDITS- THAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT. IT IS IT YES
WHAT HE- WANNACRY FOR CAN LOOK
AT HAVE. YOU NOTE. THEY'RE
LOOKING AT IS EVERYTHING SORT
OF. ALL THE PEACE OF THE PIE.
THAT GO ALONG WITH THEIR
SERVICE DELIVERY DAY. WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH SOMEBODY
CONGRESO. WITH L. ARE HAVE BEEN
DOING THE ALLEY BOB. I'M. IT
WOULD BE TO PAY. OF HUMAN. OF
HELP YOU SERVE. IS THEY WILL
MISS. SOME OF THOSE. L. BUT YOU
DO. COME IF YOU MAY ONE. AT
THEM AND ELEMENT YOU LOST THAT
CLING. SO WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
IS AND WHAT I'M FAMILIAR IT WE
CLASS. ND I USED TO. AUDIT AND
HOW TO DESCRIBE IT THE DUP. OF
HEALTH CARE SIR. LIKE TABLE TOP
ON ITS- IS A LIKE A PREVIEW
WE'VE TO GO. YOU YOU OF HAVE.
THEIR PRESS. AND SEE. ARE YOU
STARTED. THE EDUCATE AROUND ARE
THE THINGS YOU HAVE TO. IT TO
GET A LOT. TO PRACTICE AND
THANK. THAT CRYING. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS WE TALK ABOUT. IS
THE- CRITICALLY SINCE AT
PARTNER WHICH- TO SOME OF THIS
WORK. WE HAVE TO LOOK. WITH LED
AND UP THE IT WAS OF HOW. HERE
THE CREEPING UP. IT ISN'T A
SOMEBODY TO BID. IT'S SOMEBODY
WHO CAN. CALL AND MANAGE THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM WHICH MEANS THAT
YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN AUDITING
PROCESSES. THE TIME THAT'S NOT
A ONE PERSON TYPE OF JOB THAT
SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING TO OWN
THAT SYSTEM IN THAT WORK. SO
THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK AT HOW
HOW ARE THE NOTES BEING TAKEN.
OUT INFORMATION BE ADAPTED MANY
HOW ARE WE CONNECTING THAT TO
THE BILLING DOCUMENTS SO. WE
NEED TO BUILD THAT CAPACITY
THAT DOESN'T EXIST IN THE EARLY
EIGHTIES RIGHT NOW I THINK THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE BEEN
HAVING- SINCE I JOINED IT. SB
SEVENTY FIVE CAMPAIGN- IS THAT.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CAPACITY NEEDS ARE LEDS AND
THEN IF WE START FROM HERE AND
LOOK AT BUILDING THAT
FRAMEWORK. THEN IT BILLS INTO
THE GUIDANCE THAT WE WANT TO DO
WE BILLS INTO. THE SUPPORT WE
NEED TO GET IN PLACE TO BUILD
IS TO. SORT OF HOW WE ARE
ORGANIZING AND REALIZING-
REALIGNING. WORK AT C. D. E.
RELATED TO A WHOLE CHILD
DIVISION THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABLE. TO IMPOSITIONS TO DEVELOP
THAT GUIDANCE IN OFFER THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO LEDS
TO BUILD THAT CAPACITY BUT IT
ISN'T. JUST ABOUT DOING THE
BILL IN ITS ABOUT CREATING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THAT AND
THAT THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN MISSING
IN TODAY'S. THIS PUZZLE- I
THINK I WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
THIS AS BE SEVENTY FIVE. WORK I
ALSO WANT TALK ABOUT IN TERMS.
OF THE WHAT DO THAT DO. SIR
LOOK LIKE A I KNOW TELL CAME AS
A- OPTION. IT JEFF REACHED-
BEEN HAVING. WITH OUR RURAL.
SCHOOL DISTRICT- PUT THERE'S A
PART THOSE WHO BEEN IMPACT BY
THE WILDFIRES. I THINK YOU'VE
ON THE HEAT IT'S NOT JUST. THE
STUDENTS IS THE STAFF YOU KNOW-
MEETING WILL ONE
SUPERINTENDENT. HER CONCERN IS
HE SAYS HE'S NEVER. BEEN IN A
POSITION I KNOW SOMEBODY NOTICE
ABOUT KEEPING EDUCATORS- IN THE
WORK FORCE. WHERE THEY HAVE
ADULTS WHO ARE BREAKING DOWN
THEY HAVE ADULTS WHO ARE ANGRY
IS THAT FOR NOW SHE LIKES. IT
THERE AT A BREAKING POINT
BECAUSE SOME HAVE LIVED THROUGH
SEVERAL WILDFIRES LOST SEVERAL
HOMES WE HAVE. EDUCATORS WHO
ARE HOMELESS YOU KNOW I HAVE TO
LIVE WITH OTHER COLLEAGUES OR-
WHEN TEMPORARY HOUSING. SO THIS
CREATING DISTRESS BUT WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS ALSO
ACCESS TO PEER ISSUE IN A RURAL
AREA. SO ONE CONVERSATION THAT-
I'M HAPPY. IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS TEL HELP IS
GOING TO BE A COMPLETE FIX
BECAUSE SOME COMMUNITIES WANT
THAT IN PERSON EXPERIENCE THEY
WANT TO BE- BUT I BILL. SO IS
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE CREATE
THAT ACCESS THE KEY IS. A BILL
CAPACITY PARTICULARLY IN OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THAT
MEANT THEY CAN'T FIX THAT
THEMSELVES IT'S GOING TO TAKE
ALL OF US WORKING TOGETHER TO
COME UP WITH A PLAN TO DO THAT.
AND ONE OF THINGS I WANT TO SAY
IN TERMS WITH SOMEBODY-
MATCHING THE IDEAL OF
TELEHEALTH- REQUIREMENTS- THERE
IS A BILL I THINK IS I WOULD.
CHECK WITH THE STAFF ITSELF AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN- THAT
REQUIRES US TO DO INCREASE THE
REGULATIONS BUT THAT'S IN
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SO SOME OF THAT IS WE HAVE TO
FIGURE THAT. WHAT THE PROCESS
IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE. SO WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THAT DELIVERY
BUT BUT I THINK SOMEBODY
MENTION BOARD BEING CONCERNS
YOU KNOW SELL AGAIN IS HOW DO
WE- SORT OF COBBLED TOGETHER IN
THIS SORT OF MOMENT. OF CHANGE
IN INVESTMENT AND AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENT.
CRITICALLY AT THE DEPARTMENT TO
HELP US. B. YOU HAVE A CO PAY
TO BE A PART- IN THESE KIND OF-
BUT I THINK I. SAID IT'S A BIG.
AND I'M NOT THE WHAT IS A- US
DO. IS FIGURE OUT WHAT ANY
OTHER CA. AND ISSUES THERE BUT
WE HAVE A REALLY GOOD TO A PART
WITH THE TO. OF CARE SERVICES
SO I THINK I'M NOT GOING TO-
SORT OF REITERATE SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT- JACOB MENTION
ABOUT. WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESS IS. WE'RE
PHONE CALL WAY TO PROBLEM SOLVE
AND NOW YOU KNOW WE'RE QUICKLY
IN A WAY THAT'S KIND OF EXTREME
CONVERSATION GOT STARTED IT WAS
A CONCERN FROM THE FIELD. I
RESTART TO THE TEAM OVER
DEPARTMENT- SERVICES RECENT
WILL FIGURE OUT HOW TO FIND OUT
A CREATIVE SOLUTION. BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IF WE CAN GET
MORE VACCINE OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE SCHOOLS ARE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES. AND WE CAN BUILD ONE
US WILL BE AFTER DOING. AND I
WOULD SAY PROBABLY IN CLOSING.
I DON'T THINK IN ABOUT I THINK
WE TALKED ABOUT SORT OF
ROLLOUT. IS THAT. SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS
WE'RE APPROACHING THIS FROM THE
SPACE OF. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR SCHOOL
TRANSFORMATION SERVICES ABOUT
LEVERAGING A TON OF INVESTMENTS
FROM COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. TO
UNIVERSAL PRE K. TO THE
NUTRITIONAL MEALS PROGRAMS TO
EXPAND IT LEARNING- IN ADDITION
TO THE COMMITMENT AROUND- SO
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH DOLLARS IN
HOW WE CAN INCREASE. PREVENTIVE
SERVICES THIS IS A SCHOOLS IS
ALSO INVESTING AROUND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING WE HAVE TO
CHANGE. THE CLIMATE IN THE
SPACE OF SCHOOLS SCHOOLS WE'RE
ASKING TO DO SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR
DECADES BUT WE DIDN'T KIND OF
MITCHELL INVESTMENT TO DO IT.
AND SO BUT WE HAVE TO GET THAT
BUYING FROM THEM TOO. AND WE
ALSO HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SUSTAIN THIS
BECAUSE A LOT OF SYSTEMS. WANT
TO BUY INTO SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE LONG LASTING AND
EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT AS WE
TRANSITION. OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC BUT PEOPLE USING THE
WORD THAT ISN'T DEMI WE WILL BE
LIVING WITH KOBE. YOU KNOW LIKE
THE FLU. SO DO WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE FACT THAT IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT STATISTICS. WE HAVE
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO LOST AT
LEAST ONE CARE. GIVER TO GO V.
WE DON'T GRIEF. WOULD DEAL WITH
THE WHILE. IN THE NEXT WHOLE
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF IN. TAMI
GRIEF THAT HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THE- AS A RULE ARE NOT THESE
PRICE. SO THE ONE THAT PIECE IS
THAT WOULD HAVE THE CREATIVE.
TO BE ABLE TO RISK. TO THE
ISSUES IN THE MALL- AND DIDN'T
REALLY TALK. THAT AS WE LOOK AT
ROLE THAT WILL ALSO WORKING. ON
THE STATE OF EDUCATION. TO DO A
MENTAL HEALTH REFERRAL-
LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS. THE SHOW IS
WHAT COMMUNITIES NEED TO
SUPPORT FIRST SO WE CAN START
REACHING OUT TO THOSE AREAS.
AND SO SURPRISE SOME OF IT IS
O. ROLL COMMUNITIES- WHO NEED
TO GET THE SERVICES UP AND
RUNNING FIRST. SO WE CAN START-
REALLY. GETTING RESOURCES ON
THE GROUND AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
SO LET'S NOT BE HERE BECAUSE
AFTER YOU HAVE A LOT MORE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS BUT I
WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
ATTENTION NOT REALLY. FOR THE
INVESTMENT IN THIS WORK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LEE THAT WILL
TURN IT BACK TO THE- ANY. FOR
MANY THE PANEL MEMBERS- MISS
BURKE. I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION
I JUST HAVE A COMMENT I WANNA
THINK YOU I MEAN. OUR KIDS ARE
GOING THROUGH A LOT FROM
PANDEMIC WHICH WILL TURN INTO
AN ENDEMIC I'M A BELIEVER AND
THAT ENDS THE WILDFIRE
SITUATION AND- AND YOUR
COMMENTS ON THE FACT THAT
WHATEVER WE DO WITH MUST BE
SUSTAINABLE I JUST WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR VERY
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND- I
APPRECIATE. THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU. AND ONE THING YOU
CAN DO YOU BROACH TERMINATED
AND- COOLEY CONNECTS US HOW HOW
HOW LONG WILL TAKE A THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO BE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH THE OFFICE.
OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH AND TO
BEGIN PROVIDING SUPPORT DALY
ACE AND SO WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF DOING THAT NOW SO- RIGHT NOW
IT'S ACTUALLY AND I WANT TO
STEP BACK AND SO IF YOU'RE A
LARGER VISION WE'RE ACTUALLY
CREATING A DIVISION CALLED A
WHOLE CHILD TO VISIT SO THAT'S
GOING TO INCLUDE. ON THE ASPECT
OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH BUT WE
REALLY FOCUS ON INTEGRATED CARE
BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF THE
COMMENTS WE WANT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT WE GOT THIS FOR MY
COMMUNITY PARTNERS IS SUBSTANCE
ABUSE IS A- YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THAT'S EVERYBODY THEY DON'T
HEAR IT SO THEY THEY WANT THAT
EXPLICIT CONCERNS THAT WE
LOOKING AT PHYSICAL HEALTH.
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE IS PART OF THAT WITHIN
THAT SAMPLE CHILD DIVISION THIS
IS OPPORTUNE TO REALIGN IT
DEPARTMENT SO WE'RE BRINGING IN
SOME OFFICES THAT SORT OF-
COMPLEMENT THE WORK SO WE'RE
INCLUDING OUR- WORKAROUND ARE
HOMELESS AND FOSTER YOUTH ON
THE NET WILL BRING ENTITLE ONE.
TO BRING A TITLE FOR BRINGING
AND EDUCATION- IN THAT THAT
SPEECH SO WE AND ALSO AGREED TO
MARRY I'M- OFF TO SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS AS AN OPPORTUNE.
TO SORT OF LEVERGE ALL OF THE
RESOURCES- IN ADDITION TO
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SO THE PLAN IS-
TO HAVE WILL BE THE DEADLINE SO
WE LOOK IN A GOING TO PROCESS A
BRING ON A DIRECTOR AND WE'RE
HIRING THE SCHOOL NURSE
CONSULTANT I KNOW THE FIELD IS
INTERESTED IN GETTING THAT ONE
IN PLACE. ALONG WITH THEM WE
HAVE A MEDICAL BILLER SO THOSE
WOULD BE THE TO- COORDINATOR TO
SOMEONE WHO CAN HELP
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE ISSUE
AROUND BILLION GUIDANCE AND
EVEN HELP SUPPORT THEIR
AUDITING CONVERSATION. GREAT
THANK YOU AND AGAIN THE OFFICE
OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH WAS
CREATED THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR SEVEN POSITIONS. AND THAT
IS TO GIVE REALLY- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GUIDANCE SOME HELP AS
WE MOVE TO FOR IN SOME AREAS
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS MODEL
WHICH WHERE THEY PROVIDE MANY
MORE SERVICES THAN JUST
ACADEMIC AND I KNOW OUR
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND HAS
BEEN A HUGE PROPONENT OF THAT.
AND HAS BEEN A CHAMPION. FOR
THESE EFFORTS TO HAPPEN YEAH SO
THANK YOU- TO THE SUPER AND-
DID I SEE A QUESTION DOCTOR
ARAMBULA. THANK YOU UP WITH AN
HEALTHCARE. REACHED APPLY
PROGRAM CALLED HOLD PER CARE WE
RAN THROUGH MULTIPLE. AND
THROUGH THAT DEMONSTRATE
PROJECT WE SHOWED THE- THERE
WERE FOR. WE COULD WHEN YOU DID.
SERVICE REALLY FOLK ON THE
WHOLE FIRST IT SEEMS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW
WITH HOLD CHILD LENDS ITSELF TO
THAT SIMILAR DISCUSSION AND FOR
US AS A STATE TO BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES AND AGAIN I'LL
FOCUS AGAIN CERTAIN COUNTIES.
WHERE WE MAY BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
ALL THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
ARE WITHIN IT AND LOOK AT HOW
WE CAN PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND REALLY LEAN
INTO. BOTH THE ONLY A BOX BUT
ALSO HIGHLIGHT THE S. M. A. AS-
SCHOOL BASED MEDICAL
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITIES
PROGRAM AS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
HOW WE CAN HELP OUR ONLY A IS.
NOT TO BE PULLING DOWN FEDERAL
RESOURCES BUT I WANT TO GO BACK
TO AND ASK A QUESTION OF JACOB
LAMB WITH AND DH CS BECAUSE I
WANT TO FOCUS ON BOTH THE
STUDENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT YOU
MENTIONED BECAUSE THERE'S BOTH
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS FOR THE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
AND FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
IN INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS. AND
I'M WONDERING IF THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO LOOK
TOWARDS THE DEMONSTRATION SITES
THAT WE WOULD WANT TO BUILD UP
IN THE SPECIFIC AREAS AND SEE
IF WE COULD FOCUS SOME OF THOSE
DOLLARS TOWARDS THOSE
DEMONSTRATION SITES AS A WAY TO
BUILD UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INCENTIVIZE COMMUNITIES. TO
WANTS TO PARTICIPATE. IN
BUILDING THE SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH PROGRAMS. FIVE FOR THE
THERE'S BETH NOT FOR. THERE FOR
THOSE- COMMITTEE. COMPANY OF
LOS PROGRAMS TO WORK IN TANDEM
IN A SPECIFIC SCHOOL SITES.
AGAIN I'LL JUST NOTE THAT THE
HERO INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS
REALLY PROVIDING INCENTIVE
DOLLARS TO MANAGED CARE PLANS
WHICH WILL THEN PARTNER WITH
THE ALWAYS ON THE COUNTIES. OF
THE GRANT PROGRAM IS FOCUSED ON
THOSE DIRECT GRANTS DIRECTLY TO
THE SCHOOL DIRECTLY TO THOSE
PROVIDERS TO BUILD THAT
CAPACITY SO THERE CERTAINLY IS.
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A-
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THOSE TWO
PROGRAMS TO. IMPROVE THIS
EXPERTS AT THOSE SITES. I'M
HAPPY TO FOLLOW WITH MY STAFF
BUT ON PAGE TWO OF THE AGENDA
THERE'S A DISCUSSION OF THE-
DIFFERENT COUNTIES IN THE
HEALTH PLANS BUT I THINK
THERE'S REALLY AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO FOCUS ON. AND LOOK
TOWARDS CREATING SPECIFIC
DEMONSTRATION SITES OKAY- I'LL
I'LL WEAR MY HEART ON THE
SLEEVE BUT IF YOU CAN MAKE IT
WORK IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY YOU CAN MAKE
IT WORK ANYWHERE HERE IN OUR
STATE. AND SO HOW WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT THESE TYPES OF
INVESTMENTS ARE IMPORTANT IS
HOW WE ACTUALLY GET TO TOWARDS
EQUITY. BUT I WANT TO COME BACK
TO WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT
REGARDING THE SCHOOL BASED FEE
SCHEDULE THAT'S NOW STATE BY.
AS I BELIEVE THAT'S IMPERATIVE
FOR US TO IMPLEMENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN PULL DOWN THE
MOST AMOUNT OF REIMBURSEMENT
AND JUST WANT TO. THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR GETTING THAT
DONE THIS YEAR. THANK YOU.
GREAT ANY FOR COMMENT FROM MANY
OTHER. MEMBERS NOW WITH THAT-
THANK YOU- JACOB LAMB AND THANK
YOU DOCTOR LE FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS I WITH THAT WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT PANEL. AND
OUR NEXT PANEL INCLUDES
EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS WHO WILL
BE JOINING US REMOTELY- THE
FIRST IS DR MARIANNE TO WANT
SUPERINTEND OF THE SANTA CLARA.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION THEN
WE'LL HEAR FROM DR RAY VARGAS
CARVAJAL FROM THE DOWNEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND
THEN DR LORETTA WHAT'S IN OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS. SO I ALWAYS
START WITH DR MERION TO ONE AND
SHE IS FROM THE SANTA CLARA
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE CAN YOU I HEAR MY
SOUND OKAY TODAY. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU FINE GOOD. THANK YOU
I'M DOCTOR MERION TO ONE THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR
COMMISSIONING THIS IMPORTANT
REPORT. FOR ALMOST A DECADE
THERE'S BEEN A GROWING MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS AMONG
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN WHICH HAS
GROWN WORSE DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN THE LAST
YEAR INTENTIONAL SELF HARM
AMONG THIRTEEN TO EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLDS INCREASED BY NINETY ONE
PERCENT. OVERDOSES INCREASED BY
95% AND DIAGNOSIS OF MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE DISORDER INCREASED
BY EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT. WE'VE
ALSO SEEN AN EXTREMELY
TROUBLING INCREASED AND STUDENT
SUICIDES. WELL SEVERAL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS REPORT
COULD IMPACT THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF STUDENTS I'D LIKE TO
DEVOTE THE MAJORITY OF MY
COMMENTS TO RECOMMENDATION FOR
B. WHICHURGES THE LEGISLATURE
TO REVISE THE LDA BOB OUT OF
PROCESS. EVERY YEAR SCHOOLS
LOSE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
ALLEY A POP ARTISTS. NOT
BECAUSE THE AUDITORS ALLEGE
THAT SERVICES WERE PROVIDED ARE
COVERED. BUT BECAUSE AUDITORS
DENY CLAIMS FOR REASONS THAT
FROM OUR SCHOOLS PERSPECTIVE
PERSPECTIVE SEEM ARBITRARY AND
CAPRICIOUS. 75% OF THE ALLEY A
BOB CLAIMS. HAVE SOME. THIS
LEVEL OF DISALLOWANCE IS
EXTREMELY ABNORMAL AND DOES NOT
HAPPEN IN ANY OTHER STATE. D.
IS AN ANALOGY FOR MY DAYS AS A
TEACHER IF I HAD 75% OF MY
STUDENTS FAIL TO PASS THE SAME
TEST OVER AND OVER AGAIN. I
WOULD FIND THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THE TESTER
MY TEACHING AND NOT MY STUDENTS.
WHAT D. H. SIX C. S. IS
REQUIRED TO AUDIT THE PROGRAM
KNOW WHETHER STATE DOES IT THE
WAY CALIFORNIA DOES. REVISING
I'LL BE A BY PRODUCT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL FOR TWO
REASONS FIRST THE ALLEY A BOB
PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY THE ONLY
SOURCE OF SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
THAT SCHOOLS CAN DIRECTLY
ACCESS TO HELP PAY FOR
IMPORTANT HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDED TO
STUDENTS. A LACK OF SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING IS THE CHIEF LIMITATION
THAT SCHOOL SPACE WHICH TRYING
TO PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH AN
UPGRADED AND MEANINGFUL
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES. AND
WHEN SERVICES ARE HEAVILY
FUNDED THROUGH ONE TIME FUNDS
AND GRANTS AND COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAMS SCHOOLS
EXPERIENCE CONSTANT STAFF
TURNOVER STAFF SHORTAGES AND A
LACK OF SUSTAINED
INFRASTRUCTURE. SECOND THE
REPORT HIGHLIGHTS THAT ALLEY A
BOP AUDIT ISSUES ARE THE NUMBER
ONE AND NUMBER TWO REASONS THAT
NEARLY HALF OF ELEAZAR DO NOT
RECEIVE MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT.
IN FACT THOUSANDS OF COUNTY
OFFICES AND DISTRICTS HAVE
DROPPED OUT OF THE ALLEY A BOB
PROGRAM OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. HE CUTS AUDITORS HAVE
JUST ALLOWED 75% 290% OF THEIR
CLAIMS AND REFUSED TO HELP THEM
CORRECT THE REASONS FOR THE
DISALLOWANCE AS- THIS
ALLOWANCES AND OTHER STATES
RANGE FROM FIVE TO TEN PERCENT.
AND IN OTHER STATES THE FUNDS
ARE NOT TAKEN BACK FROM SCHOOLS
FOR SUCH DIS ALLOWANCES RATHER
THEY WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THE SCHOOLS TO FIX ANY CLEANING
AS YEARS. SCHOOLS ARE TRUSTED
HUBS IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND ARE
EXTENSIBILITY AND CENTRALITY TO
THE LIVES OF CHILDREN MAKE THEM
THE IDEAL LOCATION FOR CENTERS
OF WELLNESS AND HOLDS ALL THE
PRODUCTS. DECADES OF RESEARCH
PROVE THAT STUDENTS ARE TEN TO
TWENTY ONE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IF THEY ARE PROVIDED IN OUR
SCHOOLS. HOWEVER AT THE ALLEY A
POP AUDITS ARE NOT CORRECTED
SCHOOLS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THE STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS AND THE
MEANINGFUL AND SUSTAINABLE WAY.
EVEN WITH ALL THE STATE
INVESTMENTS BEING MADE
CURRENTLY. IN ADDITION TO
RECOMMENDATION FOR BEING I'D
ALSO LIKE TO STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF IMPLEMENTING
RECOMMENDATION FIVE A- WHICH
PROPOSES IDENTIFYING A WAY TO
PROVIDE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES WITHOUT A DIAGNOSIS.
OVERWHELMING RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES THAT THE DIAGNOSIS
REQUIREMENT IS ANOTHER ONE OF
THE CHIEF BARRIERS TO SERVICE
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR YOUNGER
CHILDREN. FINALLY I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INITIATIVE WHICH WILL
REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS TO
REIMBURSE SCHOOLS FOR PROVIDING
COVERED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
NETWORK STATUS OR PRE
AUTHORIZATION. I URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CLOSELY MONITOR
THE STATUTE. TO ENSURE THAT THE
IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS
DEVELOPED BY T. H. THE S. HONOR
THE GOAL. TO ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN HAVE INCREASED ACCESS
TO APPROPRIATE AND MUCH NEEDED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
PROVIDED IN A TRUSTED SETTING
OUR SCHOOLS. I WANT TO CONCLUDE
MY COMMENTS TODAY BY SAYING
THAT I AM HOPEFUL AND GRATEFUL.
IF THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS
REPORT ARE ENACTED AND THE
CHILDREN YET AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE IS
IMPLEMENTED AS DESIGNED
STUDENTS WILL EXPERIENCE A
DIRECT INCREASE IN ACCESS TO
SERVICES AND EARLY
INTERVENTIONS AND IMPROVEMENT
AT SCHOOL CULTURE. IMPROVED
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES A REDUCTION
IN SELF HARM INDIA'S AND AN
INCREASE IN OVERALL PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL WELLNESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR DOING THANK YOU
FOR YOUR VERY POINTED
PRESENTATION. AND FOR COMING UP
WITH THE SOLUTION AGAIN WE KEEP
COMING BACK TO RECOMMENDATION
NUMBER FOUR WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO DOCTOR RAY VARGAS
KERR HALL FROM THE DOWNEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. HI
GOOD MORNING- CAN EVERYBODY
HEAR ME OKAY. WE CAN HEAR YOU
FINE SIR. THANK YOU SO FIRST OF
ALL I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY FOR THE
COLLABORATION ON THE CRITICAL
TOPIC OF INCREASING AND
IMPROVING STUDENT ACCESS TO
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES INCLUDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
WORK MEMBERS FOR THEIR INSIGHT
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION AND WORK
THAT TOOK PLACE DURING THE TWO
YEARS THAT WE MATT AS THE
WORKGROUP. IT IS SAFE TO SAY
THAT OUR WORK HAS BEGUN THE
MUCH NEEDED IMPROVEMENT OF THE
SCHOOL BASED PROGRAMS THE WORK
WE HAVE DONE IN OUR WORKER IS A
GOOD START AND ENSURING THAT
ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS ADAPT TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITIES. WE SERVE. THE
WORKER DISK AND DEVELOPER. THAT
ADDRESS THE NEEDS FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES BUT
INVOLVED SEVERAL AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THIS IS NO EASY TASK HOWEVER
WITH THE FACILITATION AND
GUIDANCE FROM THE WEST AT TEAM
I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE STARTED
IMPROVING. ACCESS TO SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IN ADDITION THE
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDED IN THE
REPORT ADDRESS SOME OF THE
NEEDS AND CHALLENGES THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. FACE WHEN
IMPLEMENTING THE MEDIC HELP
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAMS.
SPECIFICALLY RECOMMENDATION TO
RELATED TO THE LOCAL AGENCY
TRAINING AND GUIDANCE ALL CALLS
AND INCENTIVIZES. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF COLLABORATIONS
BETWEEN AGENCIES AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
STUDENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
INITIATIVE PROGRAM. WHICH
INCENTIVIZES THE COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE EARLY EIGHTIES AND
MANAGED CARE PLANS INCLUDING
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH MARKETS.
THIS RECOMMENDATION SPEAKS TO
THE NECESSITY TO ADDRESS MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS AS A SOCIETY AND
COMMUNITY. AND MOVE AWAY FROM
ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
AND SILOS AND ISOLATION. AS A
CREDENTIAL SCHOOL TO. AND
ADMINISTRATOR I WOULD ALSO%
RECOMMEND THAT THE PARTNERSHIPS
BE EQUAL IN NATURE AND ALLOW
FOR EXISTING SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTITIONERS.
SUCH AS SCHOOL COUNSELORS
SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THE DISCUSSION ON
HOW TO DEVELOP AND IMPROVE THE
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIPS.
ANOTHER RECOMMENDATION OF
PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IS RECOMMENDATION FOR
RELATED TO THE L. A. B. O. P.
AUDIT PROCESS AND- AS A AS A
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR
COORDINATOR FOR BOTH THE ASK MA
AND L. E. B. O. P. PROGRAMS I
DOWNEY UNIFIED. I HAVE OVERSEEN
THE AUDITS PROCESS MANDATED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THE RECOMMENDATION
ALLOWS FOR THE MUCH NEEDED
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AUDIT AND
INVESTIGATION DIVISION TO THE
DISTRICTS. DURING THE AUDIT
PROCESS I RELIED ON CRITICAL
PARTNERSHIPS TO SUCCESSFULLY
NAVIGATE THE PLETHORA OF AUDIT
REQUIREMENTS THE FIRST
PARTNERSHIP WAS THE WITH THE
AUDIT AND INVESTIGATION
DIVISION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THE
PARTNERSHIP ALLOWED ME TO
UNDERSTAND AND CLARIFY THE
EXPECTATIONS FROM THE AUDITOR
AND THIS PARTNERSHIP ALSO
PROVIDED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INFORM THE AUDITOR ON SCHOOL
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES
RELATED TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND THE PROVISION. AND
DOCUMENTATION OF SERVICES. THE
SECOND CREDIT PARTNERS THAT I
RELIED ON DURING THE AUDIT
PROCESS WAS BETWEEN THE
DISTRICTS FISCAL AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION DEPARTMENTS AND ME.
THIS STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP
ALLOW FOR CLARIFYING
INFORMATION TO BE EXCHANGED
BETWEEN ALL PARTIES REGARDING
FISCAL AND SERVICE
REQUIREMENTS. THEREFORE I AM
PLEASED THAT THIS
RECOMMENDATION AS ENUMERATED
EXPLICITLY AS PART OF OUR
REPORT. I HOPE THAT WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE LEDS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ON ITS INVESTIGATION
DIVISION MORE DISTRICTS WILL BE
WILLING TO DEVELOP THE L. E. A.
N. B. O. P. AND HAS NOT
PROGRAMS WITHOUT FEAR OF
ADVERSE AUDIT FINDINGS. ALONG
WITH THE FOURTH RECOMMENDATION
I WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND
CONSIDERING INCREASE FUNDING TO
DEVELOP CAPACITY WHEN AND
WITHIN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THIS WILL JUMP THE FINANCIAL
JUST- REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
PART OF THE ALLEY EIGHT BILL P.
AND ASK MY PROGRAMS ARE
FOLLOWED AND ADHERED TO. IN
ADDITION BY INCREASING THE
HUMAN INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE
ALLEY LEVEL TRADE MINISTER AND
MANAGE THESE PROGRAMS SCHOOL
BOARD AND CABINET MEMBERS WILL
BE ENCOURAGED TO GROW AND
EXPAND ON SERVICES. THAT ARE
PROVIDED THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE HIGHER
ACCESS TO SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. MY
DISTRICT DOWNEY UNIFIED IS
MEETING THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY AND
STRATEGICALLY REMEMBER USER
REIMBURSEMENTS FROM BOTH THE L.
E. A. D. O. P. AND THAT'S NOT
PROGRAMS TO HIRE AND STAFF AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY TWO. SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONERS SUCH AS SCHOOL
SOCIAL WORKERS. THE TWENTY TWO
ADDITIONAL SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH PRACTITIONERS WILL
PROVIDE SERVICES TO ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND PARTICIPATE IN
BOTH THE ALLEY EIGHT BE OKAY
PROGRAM AND ASK MARK PROGRAM.
THIS WILL ALSO INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENTS THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS AND WILL ALSO ALLOW TO
EXPAND OUR SERVICES- AND ALSO.
USE INNOVATIVE AND STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIPS TO OBSTACLE
RESOURCES AND. COORDINATE THE
PROGRAM. OVERALL I DO BUT THAT
THERE REPORT ADDRESSES SOME OF
THE PARENTS CHALLENGE THAT ARE
FOR POMPEY BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND DEVELOPING. AND THE L. E.
POP AND PROGRAMS. I WOULD WORK
THAT AS WE MOVE FOR IN THE INTO
ACT. THAT WE CONSIDER AND
GUARDIAN PARTNERSHIP RELATED TO
PARENT CONSENT AND
PARTICIPATION. I WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS
ON WAYS TO BUILD HUMAN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO OUR STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITIES AND MANAGE THE
PROGRAMS ON THE BUSINESS AND
FINANCIAL AND- I DO WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER A DOCTOR IN ARAMBULA FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE WORK I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO. THANK
MISTER SCOTT AND INSTEAD WE
LOOK FOR THE COORDINATION AND
PLANNING OF THIS JOINT HEARING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOW
TURN TO- DR LORETTA WHAT'S IN
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME TODAY- I WANT TO
THANK THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. COMING TOGETHER FOR
THIS PROJECT I ALSO WANT TO
THANK TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCDONOUGH- BUT DONALD. THE
PREFERRED BIDDER SHOULD. LOOK
SCOTT ANY. FURTHER EFFORTS TO
BRIDGE THE MEDIC HOW DEVICE
THAT HAS EXISTED FOR FAR TOO
LONG. BETTER CALPERS STUDENT
WORKBOOK WORKS MEMBERS WERE AN
OUTSTANDING CROSS
REPRESENTATION OF LEADERS AND
PRACTITIONERS AS A MEMBER OF
THISTEAM OR EXPERIENCE A TRULY
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS WITH A
KEEN FOCUS ON CREATING AMPLE
STRUCTURES WERE CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN AND YOU. I CREDIT THE
WILLINGNESS OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ADDRESS
INSTITUTIONAL SILOS AND THE
SKILLED FACILITATION OF THE
WEST THAT TEAM. ON A FIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE CAREFULLY
CRAFTED. COST EFFECTIVE AND
DOABLE IT'SNOT GOING TO BE
EASY BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE A REAL GROUNDWORK ALL THAT
STARTED WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
THEN THE DETAILS IN REGARDS TO
PROVIDING SERVICES FOR. FOLKS
LIKE THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND OTHERS CAN'T HAPPEN WITHIN
THE LEADERSHIP LIKE DOCTOR LEE
SAT. ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO EXPAND ON THE
RECOMMENDATION FIVE ACCESS TO
PREVENTION SERVICES THIS
RECOMMENDATION WAS A BIT OF AN
OUT LIAR BUT EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT AS ALL FIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK IT WAS
SEEN BY THE TEAM. SOMETHING WE
DIDN'T WANT ANYONE TO FORGET.
SERVICES THAT MAY NOT BE
REIMBURSABLE THROUGH BETTER CAL
EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT TO THE
OVERALL FUNCTIONALITY OF OUR
SCHOOLS. AS PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
TODAY HAVE SAID THERE'S BEEN AN
ALARMING RISE IN THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES DUE TO CULVERT NINETEEN
AS WELL AS A STARTLING CRY
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THAT
EXISTED PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION IS COST
EFFECTIVE. THIS INCLUDES
ACTIVITIES SUCH SUCH AS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING LESSONS.
POSITIVE SCHOOL CLIMATE. AND
STUDENT CHECK IN AND CHECK OUT
PROCESS IS TO DETERMINE IF MORE
SERVICES ARE NEEDED. CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS ORGANIZER PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES
WITHIN A MULTI TIERED SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT WEAR AND TEAR 180% OF
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO BE
A- PRACTICALLY REACH TO
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
CONSEQUENTLY MEDICAL PROGRAMS
SHOULD NOT BE SEEN AS A
STANDALONE APPROACH TO STUDENT
WELLNESS BUT EMBEDDED IN THE
FULL SPECTRUM OF SERVICES. THE
L. A. POP PROGRAM NOW INCLUDES
X. TENSION OF DOLLARS TO
GENERAL EDUCATION AND EXPANSION
EXPANSION OF ELIGIBLE PROVIDERS
AND SERVICES WHICH IS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP IN INCREASING
SERVICES ACROSS THE BOARD FOR
ALL STUDENTS- PENSION EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES ARE
TYPICALLY PERFORMED BY THE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. THESE
INDIVIDUALS INCLUDE SCHOOL
COUNSELORS. PSYCHOLOGIST SCHOOL
SOCIAL WORKERS AND SCHOOL
NURSES AND FOR YEARS THAT THEIR
CASELOADS HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
HIGH IN COMPARISON TO OTHER
STATES. RECENTLY CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENHANCE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES COMMENSURATE
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUDGET. ARM
GOVERNOR NEWSOM DESIGNATED ONE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
APPROVED STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND LOWER STAFFING
RATIOS. OF THESE KEY PROVIDERS
THE DIRECT EFFECT OF THIS IS
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED NEW SCHOOL
ACCOUNTING POSITIONS POSTED THE
LAST FOUR MONTHS. IN THE WORK
FORCE BY JUST OVER 20% THESE
PROFESSIONALS ENTITIES ARE KEY
WHETHER THEIR EFFORTS
THROUGHOUT THE DAY ARE
REIMBURSABLE THEY ARE NOT THE
CONTACT THEY ARE ALSO THE
CONDUIT TO ENSURING STUDENT
ACCESS OTHER MORE INTENSIVE
SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE. SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND TRAINED TO
WORK WITHIN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
AND UNDERSTAND THAT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ARE BETTER WHEN
RANGE BROADLY ADDRESSING A WIDE
RANGE OF PSYCHO SOCIAL AND
EDUCATIONAL PROBLEMS. SO WHILE
CALIFORNIA MOVES FORWARD TO
CAPTURE REIMBURSEMENT THROUGH
THE MEDIC HEALTH BILLING
PROCESS. WE MUST ALSO AIMS TO
REMOTE THEY CONTINUE TO CARE
FOR ALL STUDENTS. SCHOOL BASED
PROFESSIONALS NO WE CANNOT DO
IT ALONE. WE KNOW THAT SYSTEMS
NEED TO BE INTEGRATED SO THAT
EVERYONE CAN WORK TOGETHER MORE
COHESIVELY. MOST IMPORTANTLY
BRACE SETTING UP STRUCTURES
THAT ARE TRIAGE SERVICES FOR
OUR KIDS. IN ORDER FOR COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH AND MANAGED CARE
TO THRIVE IN THE SCHOOL SETTING.
WE ARE RELIANT UPON SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE TRUSTED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY TO
PROVIDE A WARM HAND OFF TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TRAINED TO
PROVIDE MORE INTENSIVE. ONGOING
SERVICES. IN OTHER WORDS A
SCHOOL CAN HAVE THE BEST SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH
PROGRAMS AROUND UTILIZING
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS BUT
IF THEY ARE SEEN AS OUTLINED
YOURS. ON OR OUTSIDRS ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND HAVE NOT
GAINED THE TRUST OF STUDENTS
UNIT IS OFF OR NOT. FRANKLY I
DO NOT SEEK OUT A NEW POSITION
WITHOUT ASKING FOR A
RECOMMENDATION FROM OTHERS.
THIS STEP IS VITAL AND WILL BE
REALIZED THROUGH A COMMITMENT
TO ENSURE THERE ARE ADEQUATE
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE PERMANENT
STAFFING OF SCHOOL NURSES
PSYCHOLOGISTS SOCIAL WORKERS
AND COUNSELORS. IN CONCLUSION.
LAWS ALLOW FOR ELLIE A META CAL
TO INCREASE EXPANSION OF
REIMBURSABLE SERVICES TO ALLOW
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
REINVEST IN OTHER HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS TO
OFFSET THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
DISTRICTS ARE MAKING THROUGH
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS AS WE JUST
HEARD IN THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
HOW IMPORTANT WAS TO BRING IN
THOSE EXTRA SERVICES ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES BY USING EXPENSE SO
VERY IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT
WE CAN REALLY DO A LOT WITH
THIS. IN ORDER FOR STUDENTS TO
ACHIEVE ACADEMICALLY WE MUST
BUILD STRONG STUDENT CENTERED
POOL SERVICE SCHOOLS WHERE WE
KNOW EVERY STUDENTS NAME. THEIR
PLACE AND THEIR STORY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU ARE DR
LORETTA WHAT'S IN AND TO ALL OF
PANEL MEMBERS FROM PANEL NUMBER
THREE- TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
PANEL NUMBER THREE. ARE SAYING
NO SEEING NONE- VERY THOROUGH
VERYWELL DONE TO A PANEL
NUMBER THREE THANK YOU MUCH.
WITH THAT WILL GO TO DOCTOR
WHAT WHO'S GOING TO HANDLE-
INTRODUCED PANEL NUMBER FOUR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- TO THE
CHAIR OF FIRST OF ALL WE WILL
GO AHEAD WITH OUR INTRODUCTION
HERE BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL WE
WILL HAVE ON THE PANEL SUSAN
HOLT FROM THE FRESNO COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. CHRISTINE SOUGHT STONER
MERTZ FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES- WHEN NAY A KOOPMANS
FROM THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MISS HOPE. WE'LL HEAR
FROM YOU FIRST RIGHT. I'M READY
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BUT I AM A LICENSED
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
AND CURRENTLY SERVING AS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CLINICAL
OPERATIONS FOR FRESNO COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND WE ARE A. COUNTY MIDDLE
HEALTH PLAN. SHE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK DANCER
EXCITED TO HEAR THE COMMENTS
FROM ALL OF THE SPEAKERS. WE
IMPRESSED BY THE WORK
RECOMMENDATIONS FOCUSED ON HOW
AN EDUCATIONAL ENTITIES SUCH AS
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. CAN BE AN
IMPORTANT PARTNER IN STUDENT
HEALTH AND WELLNESS. IN FACT
STATEWIDE 85% OF COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
TO PROVIDE MEDICAL SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES. ALL THOSE
SERVICE UNTIL DEPENDS ON
NUMEROUS LOCAL VARIABLES BUT
TYPICALLY THOSE DESIGNS FALL
INTO OE OF FOUR DIFFERENT
SERVICE DELIVERY MODELS THE
MOST COMMON OF THOSE MODELS IS
THAT SCHOOL STAFF BY
EDUCATIONALLY RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. WHEN MENTAL
HEALTH IS INCLUDED IN THE
STUDENTS I U. P. AND COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
IT SOUNDS STAFF OR CONTRACTED
PROVIDERS DELIVER SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WERE MADDER CAL
ELIGIBLE. I LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
FOR YOU OUR PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
HERE IN FRESNO COUNTY DON'T
HAVE ALL FOR YOU. THIS IS I
BASED ON THAT MOST COMMON MODEL
BUT WE HAVE ADDED ADDITIONAL
DESIGN ELEMENTS FOCUS ON
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AS WELL. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN OUR COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND THE OFFICE OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
EMBARKED ON A TWO YEAR PLANNING
PROCESS. TO CREATE A FULLY
INTEGRATED. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM. TO BRIDGE THE- IT. IN
THE CULTURE OF EDUCATION SECTOR
AND THE CULTURE AT THE HEALTH
SECTOR WE DEVELOPED A CONTRACT
AND PROGRAM WITH THE OFFICE OF
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
WHEREBY THEY HAVE BECOME AN
ORGANIZATIONAL PROVIDER IN OUR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THAT WORK HERE. THE
BOLD VISION WAS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL STUDENTS AND FRESNO COUNTY
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH CARE. WE ALSO WANTED TO
ENSURE THAT ANY STAFF MEMBER
WOULD IDENTIFY YOUTH IN NEED
AND GET THAT YOUNG PERSON
ACCESS TO A MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIAN QUICKLY. TO THAT END
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF OUR
PROGRAM AND THE REQUIRED
TRAINING FOR SCHOOL STAFF. JUST
TEACHERS BUT ALSO WILL STOP. IT
DOESN'T PROFESSIONS INCLUDE AN
INTRODUCTION TO TRAUMA STRESS
RESILIENCE AND THE TRAUMA
INFORMED CLASSROOM. IS-TRAININGS HELP SCHOOL STAFF TO
RECOGNIZE AND RESPOND TO USE IN
DISTRESS IN SUPPORT OF WAYS
WITH TOOLS AND RESOURCES. TO
DATE OVER THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
EDUCATION STAFF HAVE BEEN
TRAINED AND THE EVALUATIONS ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY POSITIVE. IN
TERMS OF SERVICE WE PROVIDE
THROUGH THE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE WORD
ALL IN OUR PROGRAM NAME ALL FOR
YOU. HIS PRIMARY TARGET
POPULATION IN THE MIDDLE HEALTH
PLAN IS PERSONS WHO HAVE
MEDICARE. BUT IT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US WITH OUR
EDUCATION PARTNERS TO CREATE A
STREAMLINED PROCESS THAT
ENSURED NO CAN'T WOULD FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS. EVERYTHING
OUR DEPARTMENTS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION FUNDING WE
WERE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
STUDENT WAS REFERRED TO OUR
PROGRAM CAN RECEIVE AT MINIMUM
SCREENING ASSESSMENT AND BRIEF
INTERVENTIONS WERE PROGRAM. FOR
THOSE YOUTH WHO DO NOT HAVE
MEDICAL WE PROVIDE THOSE SHORT
TERM SERVICES WELL WE WORK WITH
THAT YOU AND OUR FAMILY TO LINK
THEM TO ONGOING. CARE THREE
THEIR BENEFIT. AND FOR THE USE
OF YOU HAVE NOW HEALTH. THROUGH
ARE ALL FOR YOU PROGRAM WE
PROVIDE THE UNDER BATTLE HOW
TREAT. AND THOSE SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED AT THEIR SCHOOL SITE
IN THE HOME OR ANOTHER
COMMUNITY BASED LOCATIONS.
IMPORTANTLY THIS IS DEPENDENT
ON THE PREFERENCE ABOUT YOUTH
AND FAMILY. THE OFFER YOUTH
TEAM ALSO WORKS CLOSELY WITH
OUR DEPARTMENT OF. HEALTH TEAM
TO CONNECT YOU WITH OTHER
SERVICES IN OUR NETWORK OF CARE
SO THAT YOU THOUGHT LINKED TO
WHATEVER SERVICES IN OUR
COMMUNITY EIGHT. ALL OF THE
MEDICAL BILLING FOR THE
SPECIALTY HEALTH SERVICES ARE
FIRST THROUGH OUR DEPARTMENT OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORD. AND MY
DEPARTMENT MANAGES THAT
BUILDING. WE ARE IN YOUR FOR
ABOUT FIVE YEARS. PLAN EXCITED
TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT OUR
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM IS IN ALL
THIRTY TWO DISTRICTS ARE VERY
LARGE COUNTY WHICH INCLUDES
MANY RURAL AND REMOTE AREAS AS
WELL AS AN URBAN CORE. AND
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SCHOOLS ON BOARD AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE EIGHTY FOUR MENTAL
HEALTH CLINICIANS IN TWENTY
FOUR OTHER MENTAL HEALTH TEAM
MEMBERS WORKING TO SERVE YOU
BURKE BROUGH AGED TWENTY TWO
THROUGH THIS PARTNERSHIP. AND
ALSO IMPORTANTLY SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED YEAR ROUND THANK
PARENTS OF TIME WHEN THE
SCHOOLS AREN'T OPEN BECAUSE WE
KNOW MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS DON'T
TAKE VACATIONS. I AM CURRENTLY
FOR THE EXPERTS AT THE DATA FOR
THE SCHOOL YEAR AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THREE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE YOU
WERE REFERRED TO ARE ALL FOR
YOU PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM AND
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED OF THOSE YOUTH
RECEIVING ONGOING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IN CONCLUSION FROM MY
COMMENTS I JUST LIKE TO. A FROM
A COLLEAGUE OF MINE HERE IN
FRESNO COUNTY. WHEN WE DO THIS
IMPORTANT CROSS SECTOR WORK SHE
REMINDS US THAT IF ANYONE
SECTOR. COULD HAVE SOLVED THE
PROBLEMS OF MENTAL HEALTH.
SURELY THEY WOULD HAVE. IT
TRULY TAKES ALL OF US
PARTNERING TOGETHER TO SUPPORT
WELLNESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES. TO
GRATEFUL FOR THAT WORK AT THE
WORK GROUP. AND THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE ASSEMBLY AND BE STATE
DEPARTMENT AGENCIES WHO ARE
REALLY LEANING INTO STUDENT
WELLNESS. AND INCLUSIVE OF ALL
OF THE PARTNERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THAT
YOU'VE BEEN PART FOR IT. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY. THANK
YOU WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
TO A CRISTINA STONER MERTZ.
THANK YOU DEAR OF SHARES
O'DONNELL WOOD ARAMBULA AND
MCCARTY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON THE
SB WORKGROUP SB SEVENTY FIVE
WORKERS RECOMMENDATIONS AND
PROVOKE THOUGHTS ON HOW TO
FURTHER STRENGTHEN THE
PROPOSALS TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
STUDENT HAS ACCESS TO THESE
MUCH NEEDED HEALTH SERVICES- WE
ALSO WANT TO THANK DH CS AND
CVA FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP. IN
PUTTING THIS WORK TOGETHER.
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
FAMILY SERVICES REPRESENTS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. SERVING ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES REMEMBER
SIR STUDENTS IN OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE AND A BUILT PARTNERSHIPS
WITH ELLIE AS COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS AND MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATIONS TO BRING
SERVICES. TO STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES THROUGH BRAIDING AND
BLENDING OF FUNDING. FOR
STUDENTS RETURN TO SCHOOL WE'RE
SEEING THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC AS THEY RETURN AND IN
MANY CASES. STUDENTS REMAIN
DISENGAGED- AS AS MANY HAVE
ALREADY SAID WE'VE GOT TO BE
MINDFUL THAT WE MUST ALSO
ATTEND TO THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS AND OF THEIR
TEACHERS AND OTHER SCHOOL
PERSONNEL HAVE SUFFERED LOSSES.
AND HAVE UNMET MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS MANIFESTING THEMSELVES
NOW- THE HEIGHTENED ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION AND THE EFFECTS OF
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF SOCIAL
ISOLATION ARE REVEALING
THEMSELVES. EACH OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS PROVIDED OF
EACH OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
PROVIDED BY THE SB SEVEN FIVE
WORKGROUP WILL HELP US MOVE
FORWARDTOWARDS INTEGRATING
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE SERVICES INTO
SCHOOLS. AND OF COURSE THE
URGENCY TO MAKE THESE EFFORTS A
PRIORITY ARE REFLECTED IN THE
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS MADE
THROUGH THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PARTICULARLY THE
SCHOOL LINKED PARTNERSHIPS WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND HAVE A FEW
COMMENTS RELATED TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE TWO FOUR
AND FIVE SPECIFICALLY. IT
SHOULD GO WITHOUT SAYING THAT
ANY IMPLEMENTATION EFFORT
RELATED TO SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH. MUST PUT EQUITY IN THE
CENTER AND USING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS THE
DISPROPORTIONATE ACCESS TO
SERVICES FOR LGBTQ YOUTH AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR IS ESSENTIAL.
ON RECOMMENDATION ONE TO
FORMALIZE STATEWIDE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN EDUCATION
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS THE
IDENTIFIED ACTIONS SEEM TO BE
THE RIGHT STEPS WE ARE WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE BOTH DH VS
NCD TO HIGHER STAFFING
CONSULTANTS WHO HAVE BOTH THE
FINANCIAL AND PROGRAMMATIC
EXPERTISE AS YOU LOOK. TO BRING
THESE SYSTEMS INTO ALIGNMENT.
ENSURING THAT PARENTS STUDENTS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND SCHOOL FUNDING SCHOOL
SCHOOL COUNSELING PERSONNEL ARE
ENGAGED IN THE ADVISORY GROUP
WILL HELP TO MAINTAIN A FOCUS
ON WHAT SERVICES ARE MOST
NEEDED. AND WHICH ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN ADDRESSING
STUDENTS NEEDS. RECOMMENDATION
TO TARGETED TRAINING AND
GUIDANCE TO LEDS AND HEALTH
PLANS ON MAXIMIZING BILLING AND
REIMBURSEMENT AND THE EXPANSION
OF SCHOOL HEALTH SERVICES IS
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
THESE EFFORTS. UNDER TO A WE
BELIEVE THAT SOME DEEPER WORK
ON HOW THE STATE AGENCIES
WORKING WITH BOTH HEALTH PLANS
AND ELLIE AS TO DEFINE WHAT
CONDITIONS. NEED TO EXIST IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT COLLABORATION.
THAT WILL RESULT IN EXPANDED
SERVICES TO STUDENTS IT IS
NECESSARY. THIS SECTION OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS CALLS OUT THE
CHALLENGES OF THIS EFFORT AND
SUGGEST THAT ALL INVOLVED NEED
TO STAY FOCUSED ON THE STUDENTS
FIRST. BUT WE THINK THAT SOME
SPECIFIC ACTIONS SUCH AS
INTEGRATED FINANCING
DOCUMENTATION AND BILLING
APPROACHES SHOULD BE SPELLED
OUT IN ORDER TO TAKE REAL AND
TANGIBLE ACTION IN THIS AREA.
WITHOUT AN AGREED UPON
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ADDRESSES
THESE CHALLENGES. IT WILL NOT
BE ENOUGH FOR US JUST TO BE
FOCUSED ON BEING CHILD CENTERED.
RECOMMENDATION FOR OUTLINES
IMPLEMENTATION FEEDBACK LOOPS
AND I KNOW SEVERAL HAVE
COMMENTED ON THIS- THE ACTIONS
TAKEN UNDER THE RECOMMENDATIONS
MUST CLEARLY ADDRESS ELISE
CONCERNS THAT PASSED AUDITS
HAVE RESULTED IN A SIGNIFICANT
LOSS OF FUNDS. IN FACT. I THINK
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE FACT THE
L. E. A. B. O. P. ON.
DEPARTMENT THE DEPARTMENT IS
FUNDED BY THE WITHHOLDING OF
MEDICAID REIMBURSEMENTS PAID TO
ELLIE AS THE SEEMS PROBLEMATIC
TO US AND THINK WE NEED TO
CONSIDER- USE OF GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT. THAT WOULD FURTHER
BUILD THE EFFORT UP TOWARDS
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
RATHER THAN A COMPLIANCE
APPROACH AND DOCUMENTING AND
CLEANING SERVICES. I'M NOT
FINALLY RECOMMENDATION FIVE
INCREASING ACCESS TO PREVENTION
SERVICES IS YET ANOTHER
CRITICAL RECOMMENDATION THAT WE
SUPPORT DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK
WILL BE A FIRST STEP TOWARDS
THIS EFFORT. AND THIS
RECOMMENDATION ALIGNS WITH
CATALANS GOALS OF REDUCING
BARRIERS TO CHILDREN ACCESSING
CARE EARLY ON THE BROADENING OF
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY TO
INCLUDE HOMELESSNESS ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND
INVOLVEMENT IN CHILD WELFARE.
AS WELL AS BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
IT PSTG MEDICAL SERVICES WITH
OUT AN INITIAL DIAGNOSIS WILL
ASSISTANCE STUDENT ACCESS TO
SERVICES. PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WILL HELP FURTHER THIS
RECOMMENDATION GIVEN THEIR WIDE
RANGE OF PREVENTION SERVICES
SUCH AS FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
THAT CAN BE EMBEDDED IN
SCHOOLS. COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
INVESTMENT IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WILL ALSO HELP SUPPORT
THIS RECOMMENDATION. PROBABLY
THERE'S TWO AREAS THAT WE THINK
HAVE TO BE PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION AS WE INTEGRATE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS. THE ISSUE
OF THE WORK FORCE MUST BE
ADDRESSED IF WE'RE WE ARE GOING
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AT
IMPLEMENTING THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. RETAINING THE
CURRENT WORKFORCE AND FINDING
WAYS TO EXTEND THE WORK FORCE
THROUGH ONLY LICENSED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STAFF AND
PEER SUPPORT IS ESSENTIAL. AND
WHILE IT WAS NOT THE SCOPE OF
THIS WORKGROUP WE MUST ALSO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS OUR EFFORTS
ON ENSURING THAT THERE'S
ALREADY IN ACCESS TO SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH SERVICES FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WITH COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE. THERE ARE THERE
OFTEN BARRIERS FOR THESE
STUDENTS TO ACCESS YOUR AFTER
SCHOOL SITES EVEN WHEN THEY MAY
NEED IT MOST. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
OUR THOUGHTS. IT RECOMMENDED TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO MUCH NEEDED
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE WERE GOING
NOW GO AHEAD. HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA. YES GOOD MORNING
KAREN COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING THIS
MORNING AND REALLY APPRECIATED
HEARING THE PRESENTATIONS IN
THE DISCUSSION THAT ARE IN THE
CURRENT ISSUE I MONEY TO MEN
CEO. FOR THE LOCAL HEALTH PLAN
FOR CALIFORNIA. HE IS THE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE SIXTEEN
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLAN.
THAT SERVE OVER EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ENROLLED IN MEDI
CAL. I WOULD FIFTY PARTICIPATED
IN SB SEVENTY FIVE WORKERS AND
SINCE THENHAVE BEEN ENGAGED
WITH THE ECSTATIC STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO DEVELOP. IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND PUBLIC
PROGRAMS WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
MENTIONED TODAY AND IS A
COMPONENT OF THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHERA HEALTH
INITIATIVES. MY COMMENTS WILL
REALLY FOCUS ON CONNECTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT
WITH THE SIGNIFICANT BURKE HAD
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS
INCLUDED IN THIS YEAR'S STATE
BUDGET. FIRST THE REPORT
INCLUDES SEVERAL KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR PROVISION
OF THE FULL RANGE. OF
PREVENTIVE CARE AT SCHOOL.
GIVEN THE FOUR POINT FOUR BILL
DOLLARS. IN THE BY THAT THE YOU
BEHAVIOR HEALTH WITH A- PORTION
OF THAT FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED TO SCHOOL BASED OR
SCHOOL LINKED SERVICES. WE
BELIEVE ADOPTION AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE REPORT'S
RECOMMENDATIONS SHOULD
PRIORITIZE SUPPORT FOR
EXPANDING ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES. TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
IMPLEMENTING THE STUDENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS IN
THE BUDGET. NOW BRIEFLY COMMENT
ON THREE AND THE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT.
THE FIRST LACC SUPPORTS
RECOMMENDATION ONE WHICH
RECOMMENDS FORMALIZED
COLLABORATION BETWEEN BEATS YES
AND HE WHICH HE REALISES
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE OFFICE
OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. I WOULD NOTE THAT WE
BELIEVE IT SHOULD ALSO INCLUDE
COLLABORATION WITH OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENT UNDER HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SERVICES AGENCY.
THAT HAVE A ROLE IN OVERSEEING.
SCHOOL BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM. WE ALSO SUPPORT. THREE
WHICH OUTLINES A METHOD FOR
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO SCHOOLS TO EXPAND SERVICES
AND LINKAGES. WE BELIEVE STATE
LEVEL LEADERSHIP AND
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL SUPPORT
AND TAKEN TO THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL BE CRITICAL FOR
THE SUCCESS OF THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. AND NOW I CAN FOCUS
ON MY REMAINING COMMENT ON
RECOMMENDATION FIVE WHICH
PERTAINS TO DEVELOPING A
FRAMEWORK FOR DELIVERY OF
PREVENTIVE SERVICES THAT SHOULD
BE OFFERED WILL BE SETTING.
AGAIN FOCUSING MY COMMENT ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. PROVIDING
SERVICES DIRECTLY AT A SCHOOL
SITE THROUGH PROVIDERS EMPLOYED
BY THE SCHOOL AN APPROACH THAT
MAYBE IF PEOPLE MODEL PERFECT
FOR SOME SCHOOL PARTICULARLY
THOSE THAT HAVE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPACITY.
HOWEVER CONTRACTING WITH
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLAN
COMES WITH FEDERAL AND STATE
REQUIREMENTS. SUCH AS PROVIDER
ENROLLMENT AND CREDENTIALING
THE MISSION OF CLAIMS OR
ENCOUNTERS AND DATA SHARING.
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT LEFT AND
THEREFORE WE RECOMMEND THAT ANY
FRAMEWORK FOR SCHOOL BASED
SERVICES ALSO CONSIDER
APPROACHES. THAT PROVIDE
LINKAGES TO SERVICES THROUGH
SCHOOL. SO FOR EXAMPLE EVEN IF
THE SCHOOL DOES NOT WILL CAN
ONLY END UP BEING THE PROVIDER
AN INDIVIDUAL OR GROUP THERAPY
IT CAN PROVIDE SCREENING TESTS
SUCH AS ASUS SCREENING OR
SCREENING FOR DEPRESSION. AND
REFERRALS FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES SO THAT STUDENTS CAN
GET CONNECTED WITH PROVIDERS
THAT CAN DELIVER NEEDED
CLINICAL SERVICES. ANOTHER
MODEL WOULD BE INVENTING A
NAVIGATOR A COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER WAS IN A SCHOOL SITE TO
PROVIDE THOSE LINKAGES OR A
WARM HAND OFF AS. MENTIONED
EARLIER. AND ANOTHER APPROACH
TO BE A CALL THE SCHOOL SITE
HELLO HOW INTEREST. THAT IS CAN
RECEIVE SERVICE THAT FROM. AND
THE COMMUNITY. ALL THIS SAY WE
BELIEVE THEIR SUMMER DIFFERENT.
TO EXPANDING ACCESS TO SCHOOL
BASED OR SCHOOL. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. BASED ON LOW NEEDS AND
INTERESTS. INCLUDING RECOMMEND
THE LEAD. LEVERAGE ATHLETES
FIVE REPORT OR IN. OF THE
HISTORICAL INVESTMENT STUDENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND IF YOUR
STATE BUDGET. A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME RESOURCES AND
COLLABORATION WILL BE REQUIRED
TO MAKE THE PROGRAM SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU AND I WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO GO AHEAD.
MR TERRORISTS OKAY- DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ARE CURRICULA.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU-
FIRST I'M GONNA- THANKS SUSAN
HOLD FROM COUNTY- I'M A BIG FAN
OF THE ONE YOU'VE TALKED THE
DIRECTOR AND THE PROJECT YOU'RE
DOING WITH ALL FOR YOU I THINK
IT IS A MODEL FOR US TO LOOK
TOWARDS WITH FULLY INTEGRATED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAM AND
BELIEVE IT'S A GREAT WAY FOR US
TO FOCUS ON HOW WE CAN GET ALL
STUDENTS ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH.
SYSTEMS I DO WANT TO FOLLOW UP
IF I COULD ON YOUR COMMENT
REGARDING- ALL WITHIN YOUR ALL
FOR YOU AS YOU ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR THOSE EVEN WHO
AREN'T ON MEDICAID AND WITH
THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
PRIVATE INSURANCE HAS PARITY
BOTH AN ACCESS AND IN HELPING
TO CREATE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WILL BE NEEDED TO TAKE
CARE OF ALL OF OUR KIDS WITHIN
SCHOOLS. AND SO I HOPE THAT THE
STATE WILL LOOK TOWARDS PRIVATE
INSURANCE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE PLAYING AN ACTIVE ROLE
IN HELPING US TO BUILD THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WE GO FORWARD
AS IT'S NOT JUST A MEDICAL
ISSUE BUT IT'S A PARITY ISSUE
FOR OLD- YOUTH WHO ARE GOING TO
BE SEEKING SERVICES. I DID WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT AND UPLIFT HER
COMMENT IF I COULD THAT IF ANY
OF US COULD HAVE SOLVED THIS WE
WOULD HAVE AND THAT IT WILL
TAKE ALL OF US WORKING TOGETHER
AS I THINK THAT IS A GREAT
SUMMATION FOR THE COLLABORATION
THAT WILL BE NECESSARY FOR US
TO WORK THROUGH AND IMPLEMENT
THE CHILDREN'S AND YOUTH%
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
AND WHILE MANY OF US CHAMPIONED
AND ELEVATED AND KNEW THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS IT'S- THE
IMPLEMENTATION. THAT WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO BE AND
COLLABORATION AND WORKING WITH
MANY OF THOSE PARTNERS AND SO
WANTS TO MAKE SURE TO HIGHLIGHT
AND ELEVATE THAT BUT I GOTTA
BRING US BACK TO IF I CAN. WHY
I BELIEVE THIS IS SOMEONE
IMPORTANT FOR. LOCAL AGENCIES
TO WANTS TO PARTICIPATE NOT
JUST BECAUSE WERE. PLACING THE
CHILD AT THE CENTER BUT BECAUSE
YOU'RE ABLE TO PULL DOWN
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT. AND THAT
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT WE HEARD
CAN GO BACK INTO OTHER HALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS AND
OTHER EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
YOU'RE HEARING LOSS IS A STATE
INVESTING MONEY INTO THE
CHILDREN'S AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE. THAT THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES HERE FOR US TO BE
PULLING DOWN FEDERAL RESOURCES
AS WELL AND HOPE WERE UTILIZING
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES AS THE
STATE. SO I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THIS PANEL AND BELIEVE THAT
THE CONVERSATION WITH THE LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT. FOR US TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THESE
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES- BUT
BELIEVE THIS HAS BEEN A GREAT.
CONVERSATION OVERALL- BETWEEN
EDUCATION AND HEALTH CARE THIS
IS INCREDIBLY WONKY AND
DETAILED- BUT- THINK THAT WE
HAVE STARTED TO- MAKE SURE WE
UNDERSTAND BOTH THE IMPORTANCE
AND URGENCY THAT THIS MATTER
HAS AND LOOK FORWARD TO WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION- WILL
PROPOSE IN THEIR JANUARY
BUDGET- BUT- BELIEVE THAT WE AS
A LEGISLATURE WILL WANTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE.
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTING THE
CHILDREN'S AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE AS THAT IS
THIS INTERFACE WITH SCHOOL THE
HOUSE HEALTH PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU FOR A LONG. THANK YOU MISS
RAYOS. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE ARE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO
ARE PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION
FIRST AND VERY IMPORTANT I AND
A FEW COMMENTS ARE MADE AND I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THOSE AND
THAT WAS THE FIRST THAT WE MUST
PUT EQUITY IN THE CENTER AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM DR
STONER MERTZ REGARDING THAT
ALSO TO STAY FOCUSED ON THE
STUDENTS. FIRST AND AS DR
ARAMBULA HAS INDICATED THE
PARITY TO ACCESS WHEN WE
COMPARE THIS TO PRIVATE- HEALTH
PLANS PLOT PRIVATE INSURANCE.
AT THE OTHER THE LAST COMMENT
THAT WAS MADE THAT I THOUGHT
WAS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IS
ABOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE'VE
HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT THIS. AND
THAT THE SCHOOLS WANTING TO BE
PART OF IT. UNFORTUNATELY WITH
THESE AUDITS THAT- THE CHAIR
HAS QUESTIONS ABOUT I AM
EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
THAT WOULD SET SOME OF THE
SCHOOLS WON'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE. BECAUSE IN THE END
THEY- THEY THEY'RE PROVIDING
SERVICES THEY THEY FILL OUT THE
FORMS THAT ARE NECESSARY. TO
GET AN AUDIT AND IS NOW WITHOUT
ANY HELP THERE ARE NO ASKED TO
RETURN THE MONEY- THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
AND I AGREE WITH THE CHAIRS
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE
SPECIFICALLY REGARDING THAT.
GOING BACK TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD ASK. IF
THE OF THE THESE ARE OUR HEALTH
FIELD MENTAL HEALTH FIELD-
PRESENTERS DO YOU HAVE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS. THAT WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT REGARDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT WILL HELP
pASPECT OF THIS BUT WITH ANY
OTHER ASPECT THAT YOU FEEL WILL
MAKE THIS. A BETTER DELIVERY OF
SERVICES TO OUR STUDENTS WHO AS
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER- SHOULD
BE FIRST. THANK YOU MISS THANK
YOU MISS RADIUS- ANY OTHER
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER DONALD I THANK YOU-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I JUST
QUESTION PERMITS KOOPMANS ODD
LAST YEAR'S A BLUES LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET HAD FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN IT. FOR MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO WORK WITH SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE A SCHOOL BASED SERVICES
SO HOW OF. HOW EFFECTIVE WILL
BE THAT MONEY WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE. ON THE GROUND IN
YOUR WORLD. AT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND I
THINK WE'RE WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
IT AND AT PARTICIPATING AND
DISCUSSION YEAH AS WE SPEAK
WITH THE DEPARTMENTS AND WITH
SCHOOLS AND COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN. TO WORK ON THE
PROGRAM DESIGNS SO I THINK- THE
AFFECTED THAT'S OF THAT PROGRAM
ON THE GROUND WILL BE DEPENDENT
ON- WHAT THAT PROGRAM DESIGNED
ALTERNATELY LOOKS LIKE AND-
WHAT I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM THE
LOCAL PLAN BY MEMBERS. IS THAT
YOU KNOW THERE NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERABLE FLEXIBILITY BASED
ON THE DIVERSITY OF LOCAL MEDIA
AND I THINK I NATIONAL OUTREACH
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THEIR THEIR
SCHOOL PARTNERS- HAVE ALSO
SUPPORTED THAT SO I THINK IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION- AND I THINK
I'M HOPING THAT THAT WILL BE
CLEAR AS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE DISCUSSION. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT- BUT WILL BE
REQUIRED. TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT
THAT PROGRAM STARTING NEXT YEAR.
GREAT OF THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- AND ACTUALLY
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DIRECTED
BOTH THAT- MISS KOOPMANS AND
MISS HOLD SO- AND YOU CAN
ANSWER IN WHICHEVER ORDER- AS
LONG AS YOU DON'T TRY TO DO IT
AT THE SAME TIME- SO UNDER
UNDER THE HEALTH HEALTH BUDGET
TRAILER BILL AB ONE THIRTY
THREE SCHOOLS WILL EVENTUALLY
BE ABLE TO BILL PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PLANS AND COUNTY
MOUNT MENTAL HEALTH PLANS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN BETWEEN NOW AND
THEN- AND WIN THE REQUIREMENT
THAT PLANS COVER SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
EXAMPLE TO PROVIDERS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A PROVIDER ENROLLMENT
DO YOU NEED TO ESTABLISH
CONTRACTS OR AMMO USE. OKAY
I'LL I'LL START. AND YEAH
LYNETTE AND WITH A LOCAL BAND
SO. AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
BETWEEN NOW AND THAT AND IT'S
EXACTLY SOME OF THE ISSUES THE
DEPARTMENT MENTIONING. I KNOW
THAT THE REQUIREMENT- IN THE
TRAILER BILL. AT REQUIRED
REIMBURSEMENT REGARDLESS OF
NETWORK PROVIDER STATUS BUT- I
THINK YOU KNOW. PART OF THAT
THE DAY I THINK IDEALLY THERE
WOULD BE CONTACT IN PLACE.
HAVING A CONTRACT IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT THE SERVICE IS
GOING TO BE DELIVERED IN A
SILO. BUT THE SCHOOLS WOULD BE
CONNECTED TO OUR BROADER
NETWORK AND OTHER PLACES THAT
CHILDREN MIGHT BE RESERVED
MEETING CARE. PARTICULARLY TO
THEIR PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS.
SO I THINK THAT REALLY SHOULD
BE THE GOAL AND NOT THAT THESE
ARE SILENT SERVICES AND BETTER
JUST BEING BILLED WITHOUT A
CONNECTION YOU KIND OF THE
BROADER ARRAY OF SERVICES. THAT
CAN BE- RECEDING. SO I THINK IT
IS WORKING TOWARD IDENTIFYING
THE NEED- TO WORK TOWARD
CONTRACT. I WOULD JUST PARA
RIGHT NOW WITH. EMPLOYMENT HE
PLAN I THINK WILL BE. A LOT OF
SORT OF. ISSUES AS WORKS. AND
WORKING WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HISTORICALLY
ARE NOT MANAGED CARE PROVIDERS-
THAT WILL NEED TO- HAVE CLAIMS
AND BILLING SYSTEMS IN PLACE.
LEARN HOW TO SUBMIT A CLAIM-
THE SHARED DATA- AND A LOT OF
THE- INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES AND
THEY CATCH ON I THINK ANOTHER-
THE ISSUE THAT. I THINK IS
WORTH FURTHER DISCUSSION IS
PROVIDER TYPE- I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE IS. THIRD ALIGNMENT TODAY
OR THERE'S SOME OVERLAP BUT NOT
COMPLETE ALIGNMENT BETWEEN. THE
TYPES OF PROVIDERS THAT ARE
AUTHORIZED TO PROVIDE SERVICES
THROUGH THE ALLEY BUILDING
PROGRAM. BIRTH OF THOSE
PROVIDERS THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
PROVIDE SERVICES NOT MODERATE
SERVICES AND COVERED BY THE
MANAGED CARE PLAN. I THINK IT'S
A COMBINATION OF ALL THOSE
ISSUES AND I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE A LOT OF WORK OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS- TO WORK.
TOWARDS THAT THAT BE GRADUAL.
SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT. ARE YOU
TALK ABOUT LIKES US. SOCIAL
WORKERS AND MET MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST BECAUSE- THERE
WAS LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
ALLOW BOTH TO PROVIDE. A BILL
FOR SERVICES SO AM I MISSING
SOMETHING IS THERE SOMETHING
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE NEED TO
BE DOING. SO I THINK I'M AND
THIS IS WHERE IT WOULD THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WEATHER NOW WERE
INVOLVED THAT HEARING AND CAN
BE HELPFUL. THANK YOU I THINK
THE PROVIDER HAD THE I MAINLY
THINKINGABOUT ARE YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE SCHOOL COUNSELORS-
THEY'RE NOT AUTHORIZED TO. AND
DELIVERED AN INDIVIDUAL OR
GROUP THERAPY SO. HERE POINT
POSTAL WORKER THAN MSPS AND YES
THEY THEY ARE ALLOWABLE FOR
BETTER TYPE. OKAY THANK YOU A
MISSILE DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING.
TO ADD TO THAT TO THAT QUESTION.
THANK YOU IN I CAN. THAT
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST.
WRITER TYPE I AM HONORED TO BE
THERAPY AND- I'M TIMES IN MY
CAREER. AND TO THE QUESTIONS
MORE SPECIFIC I WANNA ASK THE
AT. ON THE COM EARLY TODAY US
OFF ABOUT THE CURRENT SORT OF I
SHORT WHILE THAT EXISTS. AND
THAT THE- FORWARD AS TO MIGHT.
TO YOU CHECK REFERS TO AS A
TOPIC. IS THAT WE NEED BE
INVOLVED FRED TOGETHER BECAUSE
EACH THREAD. HAS VALUE AND
IMPORTANCE TO THE STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE WHOLE
SCHOOL CLIMATE. AND SO THE WAY
THAT WE ARE WORKING ON THAT
HERE IN FRESNO AT WE'RE NOT
PERFECT BUT WE ARE EXCITED AND
I'M PROUD OF THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE. AT IS THAT WE ARE
TRYING VERY HARD TO BLEND OUR
FUNDING. WE AT THE ENTRANCE
COMMENT I WILL SAY THAT I KNOW
THAT THERE IS THAT A BILL I'M
PRETTY IF I DON'T. REMEMBER
CORRECTLY I THINK IT MIGHT BE
EIGHTY FIVE I TO AT WHICH WOULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- ISSUES
WITH THE PRIVATE INSURANCE
CLAIMING. ABOUT WE ARE PILOTING
A STRATEGY BUT OUR PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM WHERE BY THE PROVIDER
WHICH IS OUR COLLEAGUES. IN THE
OFFICE OF THE SUPERINTENDENT
SCHOOL. HIRED MY MANAGER FAMILY.
CLINICAL SILVA WORKERS ADERET.
THEY ARE. TO CLAIM TO THE
PRIVATE. COMPANIES FOR SOME YOU.
KNOW HAVE AN- PRESS HAVE THEIR
SERVICES AT THE SCHOOL. SEVERAL
CHALLENGES IN HERE IN THAT TIME
TO PERMIT ME TO ATLANTA LET
THEM BUT- JUST. THAT AND IT'S
COME AND MORE IMPORTANT. THEY
DON'T PAY WHAT IT COSTS US TO
DO THAT WORK SO THERE'S THAT
THERE'S DELTA BEAT WHAT THEY
WILL PAY AND WHAT IT ACTUALLY
COSTS TO PROVIDE FULLY
INTEGRATED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IN OUR SCHOOLS AND SO
WE ARE LEVERAGING MANY FUNDING
STREAMS AND I WILL STA LOCALLY
BASED ON THE SUCCESS OF OUR
MODEL. AND THE DISTRICTS ARE
BEGINNING TO CONTRIBUTE AS WELL
AND MY COLLEAGUE TRINA FRASER
FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOL COULD
ANSWER FUTURE QUESTIONS ON THAT
AND IN THE DIRECTION OF
SUPERINTENDENT GENE VIDAK BUT
THEY ARE CONTRIBUTING ALL CAP
FUNDS AND AB ONE FOURTEEN SO WE
ARE PLANNING FUNDING LOCALLY.
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO WOULD
WE WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE ONE LAST
COMMENT ON THAT AT WHAT WOULD
BE MOST SUPPORTED TO ASK TO GET
US FROM WHERE WE ARE TODAY TO
WHERE YOU ALL ENVISIONED US
BEING. IS THAT IF WE DON'T DO.
COMPETITIVE GRANT. PROCESS
THESE. AGAINST OTHER COUNTY. TO
SAYS. AND HELP. AND IT IS REAL
KIND OF. IT'S REALLY MORE. THAT
WE THINK ABOUT WHAT'S THE END
GOAL VISION AND WE WORK
BACKWARD FROM THAT AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO FUND IT. I'M SO THAT
WOULD BE MY FINAL COMMENT HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS I
WOULD JUST CLOSE WITH THIS
COMMENT A STATE WELCOME TO THE-
TWO MEDIC CALLIN MEDICAID
BECAUSE- I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
PROVIDER THAT FEELS THAT.
THEY'RE ADDING THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY COMPENSATED FOR THE
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE- MANY OF
US WHO PROVIDED MEDICAL
SERVICES. OF LOST MONEY TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF TAKING CARE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT THE MOST- IN
IN DENTISTRY FOR EXAMPLE-
REIMBURSEMENT WAS THIRTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF WHAT MY USUAL
CUSTOMARY REASONABLE FEES MY
OVERHEAD WAS 72% SO EVERY TIME
I SAW A PATIENT. WHICH I
ABSOLUTELY- GLADLY DID. IT COST
ME MONEY AND SO. SO AND I
DIDN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
LEVERAGE- ANY RESOURCES AS A
PRIVATE PRACTITIONER SO. SO I
JUST A WELCOME TO MEDICARE. AND
AND- AND IT'S IN AND WHAT I
JUST WANNA CLOSE WITH THIS AND
I'LL MAKE THIS MY CLOSING
STATEMENT TO THE CHAIR- IS
THAT- THE- IT'S- I THINK. HE HE
NAILED IT WITH THEIR NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT WE NEED TO
DO THIS IS HOW WE DO THIS. AND
YOU KNOW THROUGH JUST THE IT'S
A VERY COMPLICATED TO BILL FOR
THE SERVICES AND SO AS I SAID
EARLIER. REJECTION OF A CLAIM
WAS USUALLY WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
MEDICAL AND THE MEDICAL ENDOF
THIS- AUDITS. HAPPEN WITH
LARGER ENTITIES. OUT THERE- BUT
INDIVIDUAL PRACTITIONERS DON'T
USUALLY RICK'S PERRANCE AUDITS
LIKE THAT. SO IT'S MORE IT'S
MORE DIFFICULT FOR US TO GET
PAID- 75% OF CLIP OF CLAIMS ARE
BEING REJECTED. IS- IS
APPALLING- AND IT AND IT POINTS
TO A HUGE A HUGE DISCONNECT
SOMEWHERE TO THE PROCESS. AND
SO I DON'T AND- BOY HERE I I'M
GONNA I'M GNNA SAY I'M GONNA.
SAY WHAT I'M THINKING- WITHOUT
KNOWING SOMETHING WHICH IS
ALWAYS DANGEROUS. BUT BECAUSE
WE'RE TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. TRY TO DO SOMETHING
NEW- I WONDER IF THERE IS A IS
AN INNOVATION WAIVER. SOMEWHERE
THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT DH CS
COULD WORK ON. TO HELP. BECAUSE
WE WANT TO SEE THE BIGGER WE
WANT TO SEE THE OUTCOMES AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THEY
GETTING THERE MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT. CLUNKY FOR LACK OF A
BETTER DESCRIPTION. WE DON'T
WANT TO PENALIZE PROVIDERS FROM
ACTUALLY DOING THIS WORK. WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE IT AND THEN
SEE THE RESULTS AND SO. IF
THERE COULD BE A WAY TO REDUCE
SOME OF THE RIGIDITY THAT WE
SEE WITH- WITH REGULATIONS
AROUND- DOTTING THE TEASING
CROSS IN THE EYES AND- AND
MAKING SURE THE DOCUMENTATION
SAYS EXACTLY WHAT IT NEEDS TO
SAY. THAT WOULD BE ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT I THINK COULD BE
HELPFUL. AND IF THAT IS THE
CASE- THE DH CS MIGHT AGREE OR
NOT AGREE. I IF COULD POINT US
TOWARDS YOU KNOW IF THEY NEED
TO FORTY TO DO THAT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE OR- OR WHATEVER YOU
COULD POINT US IN THE
DIRECTION- I THINK. THE PEOPLE
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THIS
DíAS TO TODAY THAT SHOWS THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE AND
BEING SUCCESSFUL- IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A TOOL. AND WE CAN PROVIDE
A TOOL PLEASE GIVE US A TOOL AS
LONG AS IT'S NOT A HAMMER-
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S ALREADY
A HAMMER OUT THERE IT'S CALLED
THE AUDIT PROCESS. RECALL LAW
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL IT BUT
BUT ANYWAY- I WAS WANTING TO
SHARE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY. AND UP I'LL TURN IT
BACK TO YOU. THANK YOU MR. I
WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM THOSE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
VALUE OF ONE ONE MINUTE TO COME
FORWARD WE HAVE A TOTAL OF
FIFTEEN MINUTES- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT BECAUSE WE DO HAVE TO
CLEAR THE ROOM CAUSES- HEARING
COMING AFTER US. SO IF THERE IS
ANYONE THAT WISHES TO. TO
TESTIFY IN THE ROOM. SHARE YOUR
PIN YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE TO DO
SO AT THE MICROPHONE IN FRONT
ONE MINUTE ONLY PLEASE. AND
SPEAK TO THE TOPIC AT HAND. WE
WILL AND WE WILL THEN GO TO THE
PHONES. A MINUTE. TO OUR
MICROPHONE. I KNOW THIS THING
IS PROTECT THE PURPORTED TO
HAVE COLD IT AND I'M NOT REALLY
SUPPOSED TO TOUCH IT. BUT I'M A
REGULAR IN THIS ROOM AND I HAVE
SOME LETTERS TODAY. I HAVE ONE
FOUR O'DONNELL WOULD. MCCARTY
WHO SEEMS TO HAVE LEFT AN
ARAMBULA. AND IT'S HARD WHAT TO
KNOW IT'S HARD AT THIS POINT.
EVEN KNOW WHAT TO SAY BECAUSE I
COME INTO THIS HEARING ROOM
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN
SOCIAL FAMILIES TO THE
SERGEANTS PLEASE BECAUSE I'D
LIKE THEM HANDED TO THESE
MEMBERS- SO SOMEONE CAN TAKE
THIS AND FRANKLY I WOULD LIKE.
THE BLANK COPIED AS WELL AND
DISTRIBUTED TO ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE INK
IS FORTY TWO DOLLARS A
CARTRIDGE. AND AS A MOTHER OF
FOUR WHO IS HOME SCHOOLING HER
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF PHARMA
FASCIST MANDATES. I'M MARRIED%
TO A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER YOUR
ONE MINUTE IS UP THANK YOU WILL
NOT BE TAKING THE SHOT. HELLO.
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS CALL
THAT MANDATE TO GO TO THE TO
THE- THE PHONE LINES NOW SO THE
MODERATOR QUEUE UP EACH SPEAKER
SHALL HAVE NO MORE THAN ONE
MINUTE A MODERATOR YOU MAY
PROCEED TO THE PHONES- AGAIN
THE PHONE NUMBER IS
877-692-8957 THE PASSCODE ONCE
IN IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO ZERO TWO AGAIN THIS
INFORMATION IS ALSO ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE TO THE PHONES
PLEASE ONE MINUTE ONLY FOR EACH
CALLER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MEMBERS PANELISTS THIS
IS TONY TO GUERO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. WE WANT TO SUPPORT
A CHAIR- DONALD AND THE OTHERS
CONCERNS AROUND A. D. H. C. S.
D. H. C. S. AUDIT PROCEDURES. I
MUST SAY WITHOUT MAJOR REFORMS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN THEIR AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT SAID
BENEFITS. OF SPENDING THE FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS WILL
BE LOST SEVERAL OF US HAD
RECOMMENDED AN INDEPENDENT
AUDIT PANEL TO ADDRESS MANY OF
THE AUDIT CONCERNS. THERE'S A
REFERENCE ON PAGE THIRTY TWO
THAT THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN INCENTIVE PAYMENTS.
COULD HAVE GONE TO ELEAZAR
RATHER THAN MANAGED CARE PLANS
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN OUR
PREFERENCE THE MANAGED CARE
PLANS ARE ALREADY BEING PAID
FOR SERVICES FOR. PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION- HEALTH
IS ONLY MENTIONED THREE TIMES
IN THE ENTIRE EIGHTY NINE PAGES
OF THE REPORT ON PAGES ONE
TWELVE AND SIXTEEN AND I DRAW
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE-
DISCLAIMERS. IT'S IN THE IN
TRANSMITTAL LETTER AND ON PAGES
THREE AND SEVEN REGARDING C. D.
E. DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES C. H. SS AND WEST DEAD
AND THEIR ROLE IN REGARD TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO OUR NEXT CALL.
NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND GOOD
MORNING NICOLE BORNEMANN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE DIRECT MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO WORK WITH
SCHOOLS TO IMPLEMENT
INTERVENTIONS THAT INCREASE
ACCESS TO PREVENTIVE EARLY
INTERVENTION AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES. ELEAZER
INTEREST IN PREVENTING SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL CONCERNS FROM
DEVELOPING BEFORE STUDENTS
REACH KINDERGARTEN SHOULD BE
HIGHLIGHTED THROUGH THESE
PROGRAMS. RENDON THIS VEHICLE
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT
SERVICES ACTED INCLUDE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES FOR HEALTH
PLANS AND COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
AGENCIES TO PARTNER WITH
COMMUNITY BASED CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL TO PROVIDE EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTANTS OR OTHER PROVIDERS
TO SUPPORT THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OF YOUNGER LEARNERS.
THESE PARTNERSHIPS SHOULD ALSO%
PRIORITIZE THOSE CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT
ADMINISTERED BY A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. AS THESE COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS SERVE THE
MAJORITY OF YOUNG CHILDREN
INCLUDING THOSE RECEIVING STATE
SUBSIDIZED CARE. GIVEN THE
RAPID RATE OF BRAIN AND SOCIO
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN THE
FIRST FIVE YEARS OF LIFE. HHS
DH C. S. C. D. N. D. S. S.
SHOULD BE PRO ACTIVE IN
HIGHLIGHTING TO ITS CONTRACTORS
AND GRANTEES THE IMPORTANCE OF
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE MENTAL
SUFFERING. K. TWELVE SCHOOL
THROUGH THIS EFFORT. THAT IF IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NINE FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS JUST YEAR WILL I
APPRECIATE DOCKED OF YOUR N. DA
WOULD MATCH IT TO. NEED EACH I
WILL ONE DEBORAH IF POINT
SHOULD YOU DO NOT HAVE TO SAY
AND ABOUT CHILDREN TELL LITTLE
THE GREAT YOU NEED TO HAVE A
EARLIER OF STAFF. OF WHAT IS
COMING INTO THE SPORT SCHOOL
PROGRAM AND I THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE LOST OUR SAFETY NET FOR
OUR CHILDREN FOR WHAT GOES ON
IN THE SCHOOLS. THAT'S MY
COMMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR INFORMATION I APPRECIATE
ALWAYS CARING MORE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON AND. WHAT YOU
DEVELOPED. THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT
CALLER. NINE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU WITH REGARDS THE ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY RECENTLY
ROLLED OUT THIS STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE TO ESTABLISH
SIX WELLNESS CENTER THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTY THE FIRST CENTER
OPENED TWO WEEKS AGO WE ARE
SERVING STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN PARTNERSHIP WITH A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION TO
EXPAND OUR LIMITED WORKFORCE
CAPACITY. WE'RE ALSO WORKING
WITH OUR TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO LEARN HOW WE CAN
BEST SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS AND
THEY HAVE TO AREAS OF NEED
TRAINING STAFF AND SERVING NON
MEDICAL STUDENTS SO PRIVATE
INSURANCE PLANS MUST BE PART OF
ANY SOLUTION MOVING FORWARD.
HELLO HEALTH IS ALSO NOT IN
ADOPTING A PREFERRED WHERE
STUDENTS ACCESS SERVICES THE
RECOMMENDATIONS BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND THE BUDGET
INVESTMENTS ARE A GREAT START
BUT WE WILL NEED MORE PEOPLE
NEED TO SUSTAINABLE FUNDING TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN SUPPORT
THESE PROGRAMS FOR YEARS TO
COME. WE KNOW THAT THE IMPACT
OF CODE NINETEEN ON STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH. WILL TAKE YEARS
TO ADDRESS THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT
CALLER. ONE THIRTY YOU'RE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
MY NAME IS LISA EISENBERG AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WILL BE A CALIFORNIA
WE THINK THAT COMMITTEES THE
CHAIRS- AND LEFT THAT AND THE
AND THE ORGANIZATION FOR
COMMENTING TODAY WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED YOU SEE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND EXCITED TO
HEAR ABOUT NEXT STEPS. AND I
WOULD LIKE THAT REALLY QUICKLY
IT MAKES YOU COMMENT- FIRST I
WANT YOU UNDER SCORE- AND THE
NEED TO INCORPORATE PHYSICAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS THIS IS A
UNDERMINE THAT NEED FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH UNIT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT TO ADDRESS
STUDENT HEALTH NEEDS. REQUIRES
A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AND
THEN SECOND I HAD THIS MEETING
MINOR BUT I DO WANT U. UNDER
SCORE THAT- THERE ARE SITE LIKE
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS
THAT ARE UTILIZING ALL THREE
MEDICAID ACCESS POINT. WHERE
THE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTER
IS A MEDIC CAL MANAGED CARE
PROVIDER AND- THEY ARE
COORDINATING WITH PROVIDERS
THAT ARE CONTRACTED WITH COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT LEVERAGES COOL
MEDICAID DOES NOT AS WIDESPREAD
AS THAT COULD BE BUT WE DO WANT
TO AT LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THESE SITES EXACTLY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING MORE ABOUT THAT. FROM
THIS. WHAT PART THANK YOU.
THANK AND THANK YOU FOR HIGH
THE NEED ADDRESS HEALTH AS WELL
TORN CALLER. NINE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL JOSEPH. COMMAND- I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
HOW TEMPTING TO DO HERE-
HOWEVER I THINK- IF YOU COULD
ACTUALLY FIND A CURE AND THAT
MAY BE GETTING RID OF THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM ENTIRELY. IT
SEEMS LIKE EVERYTHING YOU GUYS
DO YOU. CAN EITHER TAX THE
MENTAL STATE OF A NATURAL
PERSON ON THIS PLANET. PUTTING
PEOPLE IN BOXES OR PUTTING THEM
ON TELECONFERENCING- IS ANTI
HUMAN. AND. AND WHEN I HEAR
PEOPLE SAY WITH THAT- WE NEED
TELECONFERENCING MEDICINE FOR
SOMEONE WHO'S- SHE LEANED OUT
BLOW COMPROMISED MENTALLY.
BASED ON BEING TRIED TO BE
SHOVED INTO A BOX TO FIT INSIDE
A SYSTEM DEVELOPED BY THE SAME
PEOPLE ARE MAKING THE SYSTEM.
SECURE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
ILLNESSES WHICH THEY CREATED.
THANK YOU THANKYOU FOR CALLING
VERY NEXT MONTEREY TO THE NEXT
CALLER. NINE THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AT ANDREA SAN
MIGUEL PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES THE CALIFORNIA- WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE COMMITTEE IS PRESENT TODAY
AND EVERYONE WAS INVOLVED IN
THE WORK GROUP- EVERYTHING THAT
WITH THE FACT THAT THE FUNDING
AND PAYMENT FUNCTIONALITY OF
BOTH OPEN THE PROPERTIES SO
CRITICAL- I JUST WANNA SHARE.
FOR THOSE NOT YET AWARE ON
THAT- CILIA IN LOS ANGELES-
PTLA HAS DEVELOPED A
PARTNERSHIP OF HIGH SCHOOL
BASED WELL BEING CENTRES ACROSS
L. A. COUNTY. BEGAN SEVERAL
YEARS AGO OUT OF A RECOGNITION
OF MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE
AND LACK ™KNOWLEDGE
SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CREATE BARRIERS TO ACADEMIC
SUCCESS. TO DATE THEY HAVE-
TWENTY SEVEN LOCATIONS OPEN AND
THAT'S RAMPING UP ADDITIONALLY
PPL IS LAUNCHED A PILOT PROGRAM
TO SCREEN EXISTING PATIENTS FOR
BEHAVIORAL CONCERNS- AND AT THE
END OF FEBRUARY AND THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE DIRECT
SERVICES FOR SOME MILD MODERATE
CONDITION. TO A NUMBER- TO AN
INITIAL NUMBER OF PATIENTS. SO-
I JUST WANT YOU. NOT UP IN IN
ALL TO SAY THE WE ARE AT NEXT.
ABOUT UP WITH MY OF YOU- ALL ON
ANOTHER RECORD. AND HOW ALL
THESE PIECES TOGETHER. AND PUT
A HIGHLIGHT WERE. INTERESTED AS
WELL AS WAS MENTIONED BY SOME
OF THE PANELISTS- ABOUT WHAT
THE COVERAGE OPTIONS ARE FOR
YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS WHO MAY
NOT BE ENROLLED IN MANAGED
CARE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TO
THE NEXT CALLER. LINE TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. MAY YOU GO YOU
MAY GOD MAKE YOUR COMMON. OKAY
I'M SORRY I'M I'M A PARENT AND
I HAVE TO SAY THIS IS THE MOST
SELF INDULGENT SELF
AGGRANDIZING HEARING I'VE EVER
HEARD BETWEEN EDUCATORS
ADMINISTRATORS AND GOVERNMENT
HEALTH AUTHORITIES. THESE GOALS
THEY COULDN'T HAND OUT ASPIRIN
FOR TWENTY YEARS ARE WORKING
TOWARDS TREATING BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES SENDING THEM WITHOUT
DIAGNOSIS. I WAS JUST WONDERING
WHEN ALL THESE PARENTS IN
CALIFORNIA SIGNED AWAY THEIR
PARENTAL RIGHTS TO CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT THE STATE
IS DOING YOU SPEAK OF THE
MENTAL AND THE INCREASE IN
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC. NOT BECAUSE OF
PANDEMIC IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
REACTIONS THAT STATE GOVERNMENT
EDUCATIONAL TEACHERS UNIONS DID
TO THESE KIDS INCLUDING MASKING
WHICH IS CONTINUING TODAY. THEY
LOSE THEIR EMOTIONAL SOCIAL
EMERGED AND EMOTIONAL LEARNING.
YOU ALL BECAUSE THESE IT'S
ALMOST AS IF IT'S JOB SECURITY
OR- A JOB GRAD STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE LOST THANK YOU
MAYOR MAPP. COMMENTS TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. NINE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU DAILY ENTER
YOUR BILL WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
CHAIRS THAT CAN BE IN THIS
COMMITTEE MUCH OF THE HEARING
WAS DEDICATED TO WHAT'S BROKEN-
I DID WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT-
SUSAN HOLD FROM FRESNO HER
PRESENTATION REALLY SHOWED ONE
PATH TO SUCCESS. WHICH LOOK AT
THE ONE PARTNERSHIP AND
COLLABORATION I WANT TO REPEAT
THAT LIGHT 85% OF COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
ARE CURRENTLY PROVIDING
MEDICARE HEALTH SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES 55% PROVIDE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES. IN THE
COLLABORATION THAT TO THEM-
PRESENTED ON FRESNO IT IS THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH ARE THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT THAT IS AUDITED AND
THAT GETS- THAT GO THROUGH THE
MEDICAL AUDIT AND NOT THE
SCHOOL. SO THERE ARE DIFFERENT
ANSWERS TO THIS VERY
COMPLICATED QUESTION THAT
DEFINITELY INVOLVED
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
THANK YOU FOR HIGHLIGHTING.
THAT IN THE HEARING. THANK YOU
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NINE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRS
MEMBERS KNOW AT BOTTOM ALL WITH
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION THAT'S
SURELY FOUNDATION WE FOCUS ON
RURAL IMMIGRANT FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES WE APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION RECOMMENDATIONS
AND THE RATIONAL DISCUSSION
WHICH WE LOOK FORWARD TO GOING
ON. AT THIS FREE MARKET
IMPLEMENTED- WE FOCUS AROUND
PARENT TRAINING NO YOU'RE
RIGHTS AND AROUND HEALTH AND
WELL BEING FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH IS VERY IMPORTANT-
STUDENT EXCELLENCE ETHICAL
ESCALADA HAVING SAY IN SPANISH
AND ASWELL AS DIALOGUING WITH
STAKEHOLDER WHO SCHOOL
OFFICIALS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. AND UP
LET'S MOVE FORWARD THE BY THANK
YOU TO OUR NEXT CALLER. NINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS NICOLE YANG AND THE
COUNTY CHAPTER CHAIR FOR PASTOR
COUNTY MONSTER THAT PRETTY MUCH
I'M REPRESENTING OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED PARENTS IN PLASTER
COUNTY. AT FIRST OF ALL THIS IS
THAT TO. THAT YOU WANT CALPERS
ON CAMPUS. AND PARENTS DON'T
WANT THAT. DEEPER THAT WE
HAVING WITH OUR CHILDREN RIGHT
NOW ARE DIRECTLY CAUSED BY YOU
GUESSED COMMITTEE. EIGHT WE NO
LONGER WISH TO HAVE OUR
CHILDREN SUBJECTED TO THIS AND
HOPEFULLY WITHIN THE NEXT
MANDATE GOES THROUGH HELL YEARS
AND MILLIONS OF PARENTS WILL BE
PULLING THEIR CHILDREN OUT OF
THIS CORRUPT SYSTEM YOU CREATE
IT. THANK YOU. TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
CALLERS IN Q. SENIOR FOR THE
COLORS IN THE QUEUE LET'S GO TO
REMOTE TESTIMONY IN THE AT THE
IN THE PARK ON THE NORTH SIDE
IS THERE ANY REMOTE TESTIMONY.
IN CAPITAL PARK. IT APPEARS
THAT THERE IS NONE. ARE WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING- IF YOU'RE THE WE
CITED A LOT OF RECOMMENDATIONS
I JUST WANNA BE CLEAR THAT
THERE. THEY COME FROM THIS
REPORT. SENATE BILL SB SEVENTY
FIVE MEDIC CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
WORKGROUP RECOMMENDATIONS SO I
WANT TO THANK THE WORKGROUP.
OFFER PUTTING A LOT OF EFFORT
IN THIS A REAL COMPREHENSIVE
CONVERSATION. TODAY I WANT TO
THANK GOD THAT WE LOOKED WHO
PUT THIS TOGETHER TODAY GOOD
JOB GOOD JOB AND ALSO TANYA
LIEBERMAN. WHO SERVES AS THE
CHIEF CONSULTANCY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE- A GOOD HEARING IS
WORRIED HER ABOUT PROBLEMS AND
EFFECTIVE HEARING. IS WHERE YOU
HEAR ABOUT SOLUTIONS AND THIS
IS A GOOD HEARING. AND BUT MORE
POORLY EFFECTIVE HEARING-
BECAUSE WE HEARD ABOUT
SOLUTIONS AND AGAIN THEY ARE
GOING TO FIGHT IN THIS REPORT.
AND WERE EXTRAPOLATED UPON
TODAY IN THIS HEARING- SO THAT
IS A POSITIVE THING. HERE GIVES
US SOMETHING TO LOOK FORWARD TO
NEXT YEAR- NEXT LEGISLATIVE
YEAR. SO AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK OUR SPEAKERS THE
PARTICIPANTS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ALL THE STAFF FOR HELPING TO
PUT US. TOGETHER TODAY AND ALL
MY COLLEAGUES TO JOIN US HERE
TODAY FROM FROM POINT SOME FROM
FAR AWAY- TO LEARN ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. AND HOW WE CAN
SOLVE BARRIERS TO ADDRESSING IT
WITH. THAT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.